all right and we are live the last word
with lord cognito ibontas and ty guy
travis what is going on on this thursday
i love thursday campfires by the way i
just want to say that they just feel
better they just feel better you've been
up for a while the camp it's an evening
campfire it's where it's meant to be
morning campfires you know they work
sometimes you got to do them though
no disrespect to our esteemed guest tom
warren that we had last night oh yeah no
happy birthday i just look forward to
that open friday but how you doing i'm
doing good i'm doing good uh the
computer still lives so all seems to be
well there so yeah
um yeah been experimenting in the world
of uh our new activities that we've got
in front of us still touching on new
world
and just kind of waiting to see what's
going on play the battlefield kind of
questionable beta a little bit so a
little over the weekend dabble here and
there so
been playing a few games and things like
that but uh yeah we had a little switch
to put the guest action but uh before we
get to that travis what have you been up
to man i know you're always playing
something
non-stop yeah
yeah i've been uh catching up on my game
of the year contenders i pride myself on
having completed every game that gets
nominated at the game of the year awards
so i am extremely behind this year
because of my uh reviewing duties uh and
i'm hoping to make up for lots of time
so i've been doing that and then i'm
also doing reviews also a fun in my life
this week is uh
people have been contacting me on social
media mad about uh my games uh they
apparently think that now the games i
review i i made them and so they have to
tell me to fix my game uh this is
happening multi-platform instagram and
twitter
yeah people just hitting me up and being
like your game is broken fix it and i'm
like you watched my review otherwise you
wouldn't know to find me so you heard me
complaining about the glitches in the
game and then you experienced them and
thought yeah that guy who was talking
about it he made the game
i i really it puzzles me how this is how
they came together that is a that is a
brand new one i gotta say yeah what
like what how do you know
apparently i'm i'm pretty um i'm pretty
well known in the industry because i'm
making all types of games i am fish is
one of the ones i got okay nice i
reviewed i reviewed that game and
apparently also was it a dark alliance
was it done with that one too
no not that one it was the other one
that was busted af uh you can't remember
what a dev team for skyward sword as
well right correct yeah yeah i'm very
prolific in the deaf industry you should
really
uh
but other than that yeah i've been
playing some destiny too doing festival
the lost and i have time i'm working on
a review right now for a game that came
out today actually we didn't get the
codes until tuesday though so i'm behind
but it's called rift breaker it's like a
uh a base building uh combat resource
gathering type of game and i'm having a
lot of fun with it so far which i guess
i can say now since the embargo is up um
i'm not going to have any problems with
riff breaker i tell you
yeah
the main character is named ashley the
game's name is rift breaker i'm sorry i
miss a vagrant story remake right there
well as the developer of this
folks you can look that one up
nice
well that voice that voice you hear is
our esteemed guest so let's bring him
into the show to the campfire the way we
do
welcome so the last word number 169
i had to do it i had to do it anyway
really yeah you had to do it yeah
anyway the spooky is in full swing
headless knights are on the roam and of
course way too much candy festival lost
has a facelift this year because well it
had to as its previous location has been
locked away in the vault
as the sands of time keep flowing
through the destiny universe some of our
content flows away with it tonight we
are joined by a rather unique guest to
to discuss if bungie can actually vault
parts of this game games are what our
guests grew up on from the atari to the
series x and everything in between if a
game has a good story this is what
matters most
that also seems to carry over to real
life the documents contracts financials
and balance sheets of a business are the
stories this man usually finds himself
deep in when he isn't gaming his talents
in business economics and law have taken
him all over the world to be part of
teams deals and negotiations with some
of the biggest players in all the gaming
yes even the big three so without much
further ado let's welcome a fan of all
things mcu host of virtual legality your
best way to stay informed on
epic versus apple and many other topics
managing member of hoglaw of council at
bodmin plc oh and i highly suggest you
stay on this man's good side because
just like his alma mater this wolverine
can put up quite a fight
this is the one the only pause for legal
disclosure discussions this evening for
the information and entertainment
purposes only and is not to be construed
as legal advice mr richard hogue how are
you doing tonight sir
well i'm very enthused about that
introduction thank you very much yes my
wolverines are 6-0
although they very often start hot so i
i won't be crawling too much until we
get a little further in the season but
no absolutely that was
that was delightful i'm i'm going to
borrow that uh finds the stories in the
contracts and documents that's good
stuff
i'm very happy to be here you know we
had talked about potentially doing this
uh before and i i had said you know i
have a lot of destiny experience i've
probably played it for at least a few
hundred hours but it never seemed quite
right until you know i was shouting into
my microphone talking about vaulting
this week so
yeah it just kind of seemed like the
perfect storm is last week we talked
about a little bit we saw your video
cog and you tagged us i think i listened
to the whole thing and i was like we got
to get you on because i still i heard
them talking about it last night on real
gamer hour and it's a thing even with
festival lost this season it's different
because of the destiny content vault so
right
before we get into the destiny content
vault though i want to get uh people may
not have heard you from other places
even though you are in many places uh
just kind of how you got into
just your gaming journey and kind of
your history a little bit that you've
been through because it sounds like
you've touched a little bit of
everything along the way so
what's going on your history in gaming
and i've got to talk to about one of
your favorites but we'll get there in a
second
sure well you know i think like a lot of
people uh my father was super big into
technology um and super big into better
living through technology trying the
next big thing so
any youth before
um almost anybody we had a va we had vhs
we had laser discs we had a 3do we had a
cdi but obviously before that we had
atari 2600 we had commodore 64 atari st
and so
i was always playing those games and i
was even connecting generationally with
those games my uh grandmother really
really loved pac-man so we surprised her
once with an atari 2600 cartridge of ms
pac-man and i remember playing that with
her and she played it for i don't even
know what felt like 18 hours in a row
for a very very young person um getting
the keys she showed me how to get double
keys and things and it was it was
fantastic so i've loved games forever i
think really where my
my
real love came from them was final
fantasy uh certainly in the early days
of dragon quest realizing that these
weird pixels on screen could tell
stories that had emotional heart and
that were often
to my mind
better at that than some of the tv and
movies that i was otherwise experiencing
so i i tell people you know i can
remember where i was during the final
fantasy 6 opera scene and i kept a save
right there because that was such a big
deal for
a lot of what i started to frame my love
of the industry and telling people about
it around which is like you are missing
out if you don't understand exactly what
these things can do and as it stands in
2021 some of the best composers some of
the best music some of the best art some
of the best assets go into the video
game industry which is obviously worth
however many billions of dollars but i
think a lot of people just don't realize
that and if you play them some music on
your iphone that is you know from
anything assassin's creed mass effect 3
has a fantastic suite at the end just to
give some credit to the game right
um and and i love them for that reason
so i think when i was talking to you
about what i love about them i am always
enthused about the level of storytelling
that can be engaged with in a game and
sometimes you know that gets in my way
when we're talking about what is the
best game of a series for instance and i
tend to tilt towards storytelling
narrative plot character more than game
play or other aspects that other people
would go for and and you know one of the
things i say on my channel all the time
reasonable minds can differ that's just
a value proposition some people are
going to say hey i need to be able to
have an action extravaganza so the
witcher doesn't work for me versus me
saying well you feel like you're in a
european village walking up on your
horse and the fact that maybe the sword
play isn't too terribly exciting doesn't
limit that to my eye and you're going to
have those wonderful conversations and
in those conversations i found some of
the best friends i've ever had even on
the internet folks that i haven't met in
person yet pandemic or otherwise i've
had great conversations with and to me
gaming has always been that in my life
and i was the guy in the big law firm
one of the biggest in the country you
give your little intro paragraph and i
said you know someday i'm going to write
a book about everything i ever learned
that was important i learned from video
games put it directly in the first
paragraph before anybody had met me and
then that was me at that firm
and so that's that's been my journey
it's connected with my father with
friends and as it turns out with clients
and and i've made a living doing that uh
since i started my own place in 2016.
awesome i do want to ask you a question
quick question in reference
to this is obviously the gaming history
your knowledge the passion always shines
through one of the most knowledgeable in
the game and reference that but i've
always wanted to ask you like
obviously you have a brother that is in
game development and then yeah we should
mention that as part of this video yeah
we definitely wish today
full disclosure
but i was just joking but i did i was
always curious like
you know he went the game route you went
the law route so what distinction there
like what made you go there as opposed
to kind of you guys kind of sharing that
game route and going into game
development
i am massively more pragmatic when it
comes to career orientation than my
brother
and i say that jokingly but no i had an
economics degree i was always more
interested in transactions in business
than him period but i also have
a certain amount of risk adversity you
know every lawyer would tell you risk
aversion is part and parcel to their dna
now not every lawyer leaves big law in
an equity partnership to go create their
own place and make youtube videos so
there's a there's a different spectrum
here but
i wanted to have some place that i could
be certain i could make money and
provide for family and
one of the reasons i have a small
business that supports small businesses
and entrepreneurship is i have such a
great respect for what my brother did
for what other people do
in pursuing their dreams
i don't want to say it's easy but like
corporate law if you can make it if you
can pass through some of the gateways of
getting hired and those kinds of things
that that's a fairly standard track of
making sure that you're going to do all
right in this world
you know mortgaging your house eating
ramen for two years to make an app that
you hope will build your dream going out
west to california when we were just you
know brothers from michigan to go work
at insomniac and work at activision and
work at all these other big places i i
love that to my very core
but it's not the decision that i could
have made and that's part of the reason
i love it that's part of the reason i
support people that can
it's that's not built into me um i i
have to have at least a modicum more
certainty than the game industry so
that's really the separation but i could
not love my brother more for what he
does i could not love everybody that
does that kind of thing i remember he
went to a school to learn video game
design called the guild hall which is
that southern methodist in texas and i
got to go to dinner with them we were
going out to see um i think uh the dark
knight
i got to go out to dinner with like the
14 people in his cohort and it was so
amazing because there were bankers and
financial analysts and all these other
people that said damn it i want to make
a video game and like i'm like well i i
couldn't love these people more i'm
going to support you you know i ordered
drinks it was it was great and i love
that and i always have and i think it
takes it takes both kinds of person the
pragmatist and the dreamer uh to to make
the world work and hopefully i'm
providing good services to those
dreamers and helping making their dreams
come true which is a little corny but
it's it's how i feel no no absolutely
it's funny you say that because i
literally share that same bicep and that
that's why i didn't dive initially
full-on and i t was the the backbone for
me so it's it's it's kind of interesting
listening you say that the the
determining things i came to that same
determination with so very interesting
if i ever see this on a list i have to
ask about it and it's chrono trigger one
of the yeah
one of my favorites of all time still
played through it recently
um
you see final fantasy vii or final
fantasy dragon quest witcher shout out
to black wings he's losing his mind
because he's got a witcher fan in here
too
um but chrono trick like one of those
that has stuck with me forever
in so many unique ways and i wonder why
it's on your list just out of curiosity
because there's you listed four and it's
one of them so i'm just curious what
makes it
what makes it make the list for you
chrono trigger is a very very very
unique piece of gaming history right not
only was it so many folks at the top of
their game making that particular
product at that particular moment in
time but i think it's emblematic of this
is going to sound either cynical or bad
it's emblematic of some of the things i
think we've lost in terms of the
products that come out i like to point
to chrono trigger to people to show that
you can have a game that's i don't know
12 or 14 hours that delivers such a
massive punch in narrative and character
and fun it doesn't need to be and i love
like ubisoft open world games they're
like my go-to for just chilling out it
doesn't have to be that to deliver that
and you can have that imagination in
that kind of capacity i also love it you
know it's bright and cheerful and
colorful unless it doesn't want to be
for particular moments and it sticks
with you right i mean we've had so many
end of the world scenarios in video
games but one it wasn't quite as common
when chrono trigger came out and two it
was handled in such a unique way that
i still remember lavos i can remember i
think probably at least half the endings
from chrono trigger i can certainly
remember you know l-a-r-a for saving
certain people in the right
circumstances and uh who who can do that
now square in the super nintendo era it
might be my favorite company making my
favorite stuff and so chrono trigger
absolutely 100 goes up there in fact my
11 year old um was recommended it by me
she's playing it on her 3ds right now
while she plays
whatever dragon quest nine whichever
dragon quest is on there
there's so much to that one for me and
even just like
because when i heard when they did the
final fantasy 7 remake and you got to
see the art style and people actually
really enjoyed the playthrough of that
to me that the cr if they ever can get
to the chrono trigger and they probably
never will because as you said it was
the culmination of
so many different people studios
collaborations and i don't think it'll
honestly ever happen again but if they
could ever do that as a remake oh man
i've shut everything down i will i will
oh yeah i think they could do it i mean
i think the graphics you're looking at
like dragon quest eight you could do
kind of a chrono trigger look in i think
it would be fantastic but no i love it
and i think the other part that goes
with narrative to me as you can probably
tell from some of the references i made
is music is super super important to me
and i'll just find myself working on a
draft contract and whistling the
millennial forest just randomly um and
that just that just happens because
that's how much that game kind of stuck
with me so absolutely definitely top
five i don't know about you guys my top
five kind of rotates depending on my
mood no uh but like witcher chrono
trigger final fantasy vi is my final
fantasy um in those types of games
technically star control 2 which i
didn't include is my favorite game of
all time uh but maybe someday i'll
stream that or something and then we can
introduce the world to that uh that
magnum opus
no doubt
travis what would you like to know about
this man
well first i would like to
once again state my disagreement with
everyone who thinks that the witcher's
combat isn't good i i really don't
understand that i i i mean the story is
is obviously the main reason you're
there and being in the world but like i
love the combat in that game and every
every time somebody tells me the
combat's not good i'm like what are you
talking about i don't you could ride in
your space
i could write an essay on how the
witchers combat is exactly what it needs
to be and that if you had something like
bayonetta as the fights in the witcher
takes away from the focus of what the
balance of the game should be i actually
really like the witchers well what i
particularly like i play that this is
it's not a humble break or anything this
is just how i play the witcher on on
death march because i like to have to
think oh i'm going to figure out what
this monster is and sit in the forest
and code everything and take my right
potions and make sure my toxicity is
right i like the preparation it's almost
the you know death stranding of the
witcher yeah all right we're going to
figure out what this is and then hitting
the a button is almost secondary to i
did everything right and i was ready to
take on this ghoul or whatever and i
love that
yeah if you're if you read the books
that's like what the witcher does too
like it's all preparation and doing
rituals and that's why they added that
meditation uh mechanic to the game like
i i mean obviously that that's my
favorite game of all time which are
three so like i will defend it but i
just have never under i've never
understood the uh the negativity toward
its combat because i've always thought
it was kind of perfect
i really think it's because it's not
devil may cry and i think if you really
think about it that would that would
take away from the actual experience of
witcher
yeah i i do not want to think of a hack
and slash like full-on hack and slash
devil may cry witcher that sounds awful
um
yeah so you
went over your history with the game why
don't we jump into destiny a little bit
and tell us about your history with
destiny obviously you
this this game hits a little close to
home with you uh so your kind of
relationship right now because we're
gonna talk about the vault as it stands
this year uh so my brother works at the
subsidiary of activision called high
moon studios um and while activision and
bungie were working together
occasionally they would bring in one of
the subsidiary studios to really support
the game and i can
i could say all this this is all public
um and tom never shares with me anything
that's non-public if anybody's listening
but um
hey
but i really try not to ask him i try
not to put people in that situation but
highmane studios was tasked with helping
do forsaken the first major expansion
for for destiny 2. um and you can read
articles about this in fact i did when i
was doing the video on the vault i
pulled out an edge article from 2018
that was talking about hyman studios
really taking the lead
on this project so as a full disclaimer
my brother very definitely worked
extensively
on forsaken which was announced as
getting vault and vaulted on october 7th
and specifically he vote where he worked
very extensively on the scorn
um so
people can take that as they will i'm
going to say some things about how i
feel about the vaulting
and
i do have that family relationship
absolutely um outside of that i'm happy
to talk about destiny i've been a bungee
fan forever um i my first introduction
to bungie was marathon
um yeah i would love to see more
underrated well that's narrative right
bungie was already at the time
messing with ais going crazy with the
limited
set of tools that they had which were
essentially 2d wolfenstein type
environments where you'd occasionally
come up on a computer that would tell
you the coolest little sci-fi short
story that you could imagine and so
marathon was one of my favorites that
kind of goes into
i think the next thing i played from
them was myth
which was a very cool real-time strategy
type game and then that leads of course
into halo and a brief sojourn to oni
uh
and and then but and then and then
destiny so you know they announced
destiny um and i my recollection is it's
a little while from an announcement to
when you get to play it and then i got
to play the alpha um and i was
really enthused about what it was
because it was so weird i mean if you
think back to playing the alpha of
destiny it's like what
what is this what are they trying to
sell like i was interested as a game
industry fan for okay you're saying it's
not halo you give a whole thing about
how i can walk to that mountain if i
want to forget that for a second but but
what is the alpha and so i got in there
really liked it and then found myself
like thinking about it the alpha was
however many days long it's like i don't
want i kind of kind of want to drop some
of those hexagon things that glow a
little bit more that was that was a good
time and then they had a beta and then
the game came out and i have to say when
destiny 1 came out again going back to
love a narrative
um
i i don't know i don't know what i don't
know what the heck was happening in that
story right at some point we're on mars
and there was there was a garden and we
killed some stuff
um and there was like a blue person and
a robot i think and anyone had enough
time we just know there was not enough
time
there was never
well it's like i think that was a
thorough description of the campaign
paul mccartney showed up at some point
yeah
um but like i really liked it i mean the
one thing dusty managed to to master
from from moment one is that 30 seconds
of fun that bungie's always after i mean
that the gun play in destiny i think is
basically unmatched um and so that's
what makes it work for me when it's
working for me
um
when it's not
uh it's it's pretty impenetrable if you
take some time off if you forget what's
going on um but destiny 2 rolled around
and you know activision was i don't know
how to describe it activision was call
of duty marketing it you know you had
the the the front of the box where
everybody kind of looked like a soldier
uh you had some of those uh
demonstrations where i was like i'm not
sure about this and the red war was i
think i jokingly uh my brother was was
helping on that time i think i jokingly
said hey you know it's a space gorilla
gets angry we kill the space girl or
something like that right
um and it was much better than the first
campaign but it wasn't until forsaken
that i really thought okay
and i understand that i thought that
tom tom is the most confidential person
on he is
activision i mean this sincerely he is
the most observant of your nda out of
anybody on earth and i'm his brother and
he refuses to tell me what game he's
working on literally let alone what he's
working on uh entirely so forsaken comes
out i say tom you got to play this this
is awesome he's like oh do i
then he managed to tell me what he did
in it and i i thought that was such a
fantastic
campaign and idea with the eight barons
um and i was over nathan fillion so that
didn't bother me too terribly much
and then
you know
i kind of dropped off after forsaken
only because what's the one after that
shadow keep each other you guys know
better than me
so so i i like played a couple of
missions i was like uh you know i've
been on the moon and then that just kind
of trailed off a little bit
um until destiny showed back up on game
pass uh with beyond light where i pop
back in
um and so you know i was talking to
bontis about whether i should come on
and i was like
you guys are experts i don't know i
can't talk about exotic quests or
god rolls or vaults uh at least not you
know raiding neither can we we're just
making that outfit
we wing it every day
the beauty of it is i i love to play
everything basically i like to touch
everything i i don't get very far in a
lot of stuff if i do that says something
about how i feel about the game
um but
so i've i've enjoyed destiny it's got to
be at least a few hundred hours um at
this point but
yeah it's uh
it's not my only game so i don't know it
as much as like the real real real
experts no doubt before i pass it to e
um i did want to ask y'all in fact yeah
like
give me i know you said gun play
i know you said when it has that
moment-to-moment combat but i need to
know like
what was the period like that it really
resonated with you that it hit what did
it take all the way up to forsake you
like what was the matter of fact let's
start with d1 because what was the demo
that kept you there that kept you
invested we know it had its flaws we
know that story was all over the place
but at the end of the day like what was
it that you were like i know for a lot
of some people it was vault you know
other people have different things their
first exam like what was that moment
where you like yeah okay
so yeah just to give my bona fides or
lack thereof i've probably only ever
made it like a couple checkpoints into a
raid period okay um so that's just not
my
style of playing and that's mostly old
man syndrome that's mostly having to
coordinate is just impossible um as you
know it was hard enough to be like can i
do this time for this for this show
um so that has just never been part of
my um
experience because the one person that
could organize it is my brother west
coast east coast raid coordination
tricky thing
um so i never really got very far that i
will tell you the the biggest memory i
have of destiny and why i stuck with it
is kind of more of a concept which is
when it's working well and i see this a
lot
i think mostly when i was experiencing
crucible but when it's working well it
delivers the fantasy of space wizards
fighting
with space magic in a way that i don't
think any game matches really and that's
that might be partly my love of star
wars uh or other kind of science fiction
conceits but when you've got like people
hover flying in various places hurling
colored balls at each other while also
you hear gunfire everywhere there are
moments in playing destiny where that
just really all comes together in a
fashion we're just like this is the best
thing ever um and
you know i'm not
quite as conditioned for some of the the
bar filling exercises and kind of the
loop arounds um i tend to bounce off
them a little bit more uh but
that moment you know obviously you start
the game popping fallen's heads off like
that's just the perfect animation in
gunplay that just works really really
well um and then i actually quite
enjoyed crucible i'm no pvp master um
and my my brother's you know my
brother's game call of duty i'm the
literal worst at um so destiny is a
little bit better i joke with him and
it's like this one i'm i'm not awful at
uh whether that's time to kill or just
too many buttons it's like it's not as
bad as call of duty so that's always
nice isn't that isn't that the way with
multiplayer it's like hey
i'm not terrible at destiny that'll keep
me here a little bit more yep for all i
know is all bots i don't know but um but
yeah that that's that's the magic to me
is is you know floating down hurling a
grenade doing a different thing over
this direction getting two kills
and
that's what i that's what i remember it
certainly wasn't the narrative as much
as i wanted it to be um i'm an explorer
type gamer so i did enjoy kind of going
through the environments and figuring
out patrols especially in destiny 1
where you didn't have a map and like
trying to just kind of coordinate where
you are and where you haven't been that
was kind of interesting as kind of a
cartographer
um but that's that's really really what
i remember is that kind of it can do
space wizards in a magical way if it all
hits exactly right
no i think you said it pretty well
because it is that moment where
as you said things are just kind of all
firing on all cylinders you're in
just that literal zone whether you cast
nova bomber you have a bubble and you've
got enemies coming over here and you've
got a couple teammates and
as it does kind of feel like you're in
the middle of a science fiction movie
that you probably watched whether it was
star wars or whatever it was it feels
like you're in something
that you never thought you would be and
if you kind of those moments click every
so often where you're like damn this is
kind of awesome it's that's very well
phrased i like that because
as you said the loops sometimes like the
grinds in this game can just
you know
really get to you at a point and like
travis is over here just like shaking
his head about as hard as possible and
and those believe me i get i sat there
and worked my brain like you know i kind
of had a lot of deaths to a legend
shattered throne and i got done i'm like
again why am i doing so you have those
questions on the other side as well and
you're going but it's the moment since
you said it works that somehow just like
kind of keeps poking you to be like
right come back this is still fun
the other thing is that the story and
destiny is now pretty good and it's been
good for a while but a you have to
search for it and b
with the weekly drips and all the stuff
you have to do it's not worth the time
investment like even if the story was 10
times better it probably still wouldn't
be worth it because you have to be in
the game every week doing at least a
couple hours of play just to get like a
small piece of the story and so to your
point it it it only works as a package
it works because it succeeds at the
level that it does at so many things it
succeeds at the campaign it succeeds it
multiplayer it kind of succeeds its
story and now it's sort of getting to a
place where it's doing really well at a
lot of stuff but the the core gameplay
is what has always kept it alive i think
and and probably raids i know that's not
your bag but that's like a you know i
think a lot of people play yeah people
love the race yeah
absolutely yeah it's not pvp though it
certainly isn't
it's keeping people in the game
don't you start as cog and i have
mentioned
i haven't been to the lighthouse since
the original recipe i haven't been any
i was kind of figuring figuring it out
because the lighthouse now is in mercury
right so they just they just yeah it's a
simulation forget that
it's a simulation yeah yeah you're gonna
ask the question i was like wait isn't
mercury in like the darkness or i can't
remember what the excuse was it's in the
dark vault of the darkness content vault
well that's about as good as we can get
for a segway there so we may as well
take it um and this is why i actually
you had a 36 minute video over this
discussion last week we talked about it
a little bit i mean honestly you could
have gone on much longer because there's
opinions to have on
definitely a lot of different topics on
this and it's the destiny content vault
literally festival of the lost this week
our new
activity had to change theoretically had
to change i'm still not entirely sure if
it did
but supposedly it changed because
obviously previously we were wandering
around the haunted forest which was on
mercury and that got chunked in the
vault along with about four other
planets and then recently we got news as
to what else is going and what's going
in there is all that stuff that your
beloved sibling
worked his butt off on that got you back
in and now you're like now this is going
away it's going to the fault new players
can't experience it and i really enjoyed
how you broke down even the end user
license agreement and everything so i
don't understand your thunder oh i know
that was like that was your whole like
breaking it down can you actually do it
so
i wanted to get your kind of take on it
and as much details you'd like to go
into as to
you know
basically is this something they're
allowed to do not in you know a brief
summit you don't have to rehash
everything you said but you know kind of
bring some people up to speed as to
what you were what you were talking
about on your side
absolutely so you know this this breaks
on what like october 7th
um and uh i'm doing what i'm doing i'm
on social media and the great part of of
having some kind of presence is that i'm
i'm the game law guy so people start
pinging me and dm'ing me all over the
place can they do this it's like well
you know they did it last year
if a giant corporation does a thing you
can at least assume it was vetted they
might be being dumb
uh but you could at least assume
somebody looked at it uh but i said yeah
you know what it'd be a good video
especially when i found out it was
forsaken because you know one of the
weird experiences that i've had is
i am perpetually onboarding things in
mmos i always like to try the new user
experience i i'm starting over again
because i do like that narrative and i
forget what's happening and which space
gorilla is angry at the other space
gorilla and whatever it might be
so
i was on boarding a new character and
experiencing
what is it new light i think they call
that kind of early tutorial space and i
got to the end of it and there's just
this gaping maw between where you are in
terms of power level and like where they
say you should be for whatever they're
doing right now and i'm like well
what what should i do and basically it
looks like we'll go do one of our old
things that we pretend is a memory and
and go do that and i'm like
i'll do freaking i love forsaken and and
this was like three weeks ago and i'm
playing through four seconds like oh
yeah this is the best this is look at
these cgi ah this is great
um and then like three weeks later oh
yeah we're totally getting rid of that
it's like okay
uh so i did want to talk about it
because people were asking and i really
do think forsaken is great it's a part
of the story and i do feel like there's
a fracturing in terms of without the red
war and without everything else that i
kind of knew and remember remembered
going through there's like this weird
here you are here's the universe and
here's six boxes and hear these things i
think onboarding is very very tricky for
them right now so um i think getting rid
of in my opinion their best campaign at
least their their best kind of
consolidated campaign is a rough thing
and then the corporate lawyer and me you
know kicks in and certainly one of the
things we do in virtual legality on my
channel is
often answer a kind of can they do that
i should make it a sub series can they
do that the answer is almost always i
like that
can they do but
yeah can they do that with rick
the answer is yes
um
so i wanted to go through the end user
licensing i want to talk about the
situation i want to point out that
bungie is currently on their store
selling forsaken for 25 dollars
and have this kind of conversation
um and so yeah i went into the terms of
use you can check out that virtual
legality uh episode if you're interested
uh you'll notice the big vault of glass
uh in the in the thumbnail
and i went through and i looked at the
definitions and i found which i got on
my screen right now and i'll just read
it
uh quote unquote live content capital l
capital c
consists of content provided to program
users
in connection with the use of the
program
lawyers right good sentence
and so the traditional way of thinking
about live content and the way that they
reference it throughout the rest of
their license agreement is the concepts
that you're used to thinking about
seasonal content activities things we're
going to move in and out it's live
instead what they have said with that
sentence and we'll talk about it in the
parenthetical that they included and i
skipped is everything in the game is
live content destiny is live content and
then the later sentence of course is
live content may be altered removed
deleted or discontinued by bungie at any
time even if you've not used it or
otherwise engage with it prior to ultra
alteration removal deletion or
discontinuation so lawyers at bungie
headquarters said whole games live
content
and we can do whatever we want with it
at any time now chances are this
language changed a little bit over the
course of a couple of years that's how
these things work we can really only
look at the current one you probably
bought destiny or forsaken and a year
prior to this but suffice to say what
they have said is everything can go and
in that parenthetical that i skipped
that includes unlockable content gear
live events activities destinations you
know your planets account stats virtual
assets virtual currencies which i did
flag in my video i was like you could do
what now with the currencies codes and
achievements and then
the only place that they remotely made a
mistake is when they talk about the live
content being removed in the
parenthetical there they say for example
upon termination of the agreement or
cessation of online support for the
program in that parenthetical the
context is yeah if we eject you because
you're cheating or using bad words
whatever else you're doing or if we turn
off the whole thing
of course
that's allowed we can always turn off
our game right we know that we've been
we've been living now for a decade or
more with the announcement that sony's
turning off whatever game you forgot
that you had played six years ago yep
that's not unusual what's more unusual
is the concept of we can start lopping
off season one and season two and season
three
and
from a legal perspective it's pretty
clear that the language says that they
can now in my video i go into a little
deeper because people really want to
know if they can fight it at all about
good faith and fair dealing which is a
generalized kind of equitable argument
that says
you have to have the benefit of the
bargain that you think you're getting
and so they can't just do really weird
stuff and the example i like to use is
you know bungie has those sentences they
couldn't lop off all the content and
replace it with an accounting calculator
and and get away with it that's the kind
of thing where the court will say all
right that's not what anybody expected i
don't care what the words say but when
you talk about we're gonna get rid of
mars we're gonna get rid of mercury
we're gonna get rid of leviathan we're
going to get rid of forsaken you might
have a better argument now forsaken's
unusual insofar as destiny 2 had all
this other stuff that they got rid of
but that was the whole package and stuff
was getting added onto it and grafted
onto it forsaken was sold separately
forsaken is still sold separately right
now which i hate
and it doesn't have doesn't have a
warning on it it was the weirdest thing
because you go back to that blog
that bungie put forward they say hey
this is what we're gonna do you can even
tell they're couching it kind of at the
time they know there's going to be some
some blow back but we're going to give
it to you free i think on december 7th
yeah i think something something like
anniversary stuff
yeah and then it'll be available to you
until the february 22nd and i said well
that's super weird because you can buy
it for 25 dollars right now it'll be
free to you in six weeks and it'll be
gone in another two months so
if i'm bungee just maybe even for
marketing i probably make it free when i
put that blog post up i don't know
exactly why they're gathering 25 for the
next six weeks somebody somewhere on the
planet earth is gonna get taken by that
money uh that's just the way these
things work and so that's not what i
would have done and i don't like this
model at all i mean we can talk about
the practicality separate from the
legalities at some point but for the
people asking
about the law for the most part this
software license agreement is very very
very built towards bungie not that
unusual
but they reserve the right to do this
kind of thing so it's really more
of a practical complaint what is legal
is not always right
what is right is not always legal and
the corollary of course illegal and
wrong
i don't love what they're doing here for
any number of reasons but as far as the
license itself goes
yeah their council looked at this when
they wrote it and when they when they
did this
i wanted to ask you a quick question
yeah
um in reference to obviously i know your
frustration with the model the the
that's the content vault totally
understand where you're coming from my
question is you know
is this a precedent it has there been
another i know it's not a lot of mmos
but has it been another mmo that has
done similar i know travis is shaking
his neck because i think you kind of you
alluded to last last word you know that
there was so travis could you enlighten
me because i don't play a lot of other
mmo so i i'm very curious yeah help me
with the game yeah absolutely yeah so my
um i did watch your video from beginning
to adah hoke and i think
the the part that i disagree with you on
is the classification and comparison of
destiny to other mmos uh because the mmo
model is
pretty different from what destiny's
doing and if i had to classify destiny i
would say that it's closer to a games as
a service game like fortnite or apex and
those games get rid of content all the
time the the model is a little bit
different the fortnight was a paid game
at first and now it's kind of gone free
to play but it's it's extremely common
and i would say it's even just part of
like the industry changing and the way
that the model is that like if you're
not there when the fortnite world
explodes at the end of the season you
don't get that content right you you
miss that event and destiny has actually
done those sorts of live events where
you have to be logged on that hour or
you're going to miss it and they do the
season pass model they do seasonal
content that's gone as soon as the
week's over you can't play that content
anymore that sort of thing and i think
that that model is a little bit
different from mmos and if you're
comparing it to a games as a service
this is extremely common content gets
added and removed all the time um
the model that your head is
distinguished by the business right so
so fortnight never sold you the comet
hits the fortnite island campaign
and then is taking it away right so i
totally am okay with the seasonality
concept in fact when i was going to look
at the definition of live content i
assumed that bungie would call it that
kind of thing seasonality passes
whatever
i do get that and and and certainly
there's a difference between kind of
free-to-play approach and a paid
approach but most specifically with
forsaken even over the baseline game
that's where i think it's kind of the
most highlighted and emboldened which is
like the mistaken box is not the
forsaken box when this is done correct
yeah yeah and so that's a part where and
we talked about this last week where i
think
destiny's business model hasn't evolved
with their game their game how uses a
service model and their their their way
that they're charging people hasn't
evolved at all and in fact they've done
stuff to to uh make their game align
more with the service model like add
micro transactions like ads passes which
were with eververse which was not in the
game when it originally launched so
they've made those changes but they have
failed to remove their old model of
selling ucs and passes and that sort of
stuff and so i think my theory is
eventually they will go that way they'll
just charge you for season passes the
expansions won't cost you anything but
at some point if they're
you know they're getting rid of the old
expansions to make way for this new
model that's obviously going to create
some friction and
i totally agree with what you said in
the video that like you got to be on the
on the consumer side on this and in this
case the consumer is sort of getting a
a you know they're getting a raw deal
and it doesn't feel like they like when
you bought forsaken you didn't know this
was going to happen in the same way that
you might know now if you bought a
season pass that it wouldn't go away or
that it would go away so i i think it's
it's really interesting but i think it
has more to do with our industry
evolving and the way that games are made
and the way content is given versus the
old way of like monetization and destiny
is super ahead on one side and way
behind on the other and they just have
to they have to make their model align
with the game that they've now created i
think that's like the biggest thing the
other thing that i would really like to
see is if it really is a technical
limitation which i don't 100 buy that
because as you've pointed uh world of
warcraft does it has a lot more
complicated fantasy
final fantasy 14 has like uh 10
campaigns you can play right now um
i think if it is if it is a technical
limitation they need to give players
access to the vault fine take it out of
the game put it in a vault but let me
access the vault through a separate app
where i can just play the campaign there
and that way it doesn't affect the
player base or the download sides or
that that and other games do that by the
way like there's
you know you play like crackdown even
the halo infinite it's gonna have two
separate apps then they're selling you
one separate from the other uh so yeah
that that's that's my thoughts on it but
i like that idea vaulted estimate i love
it i want it sure
before i give it back to ease that uh
you you you [ __ ] some twitter spiciness
right i ain't gonna let you go with this
one
all right what do i do now all right
that's my question all
you know fellow analysts you know you
know dave we always talk a destiny fan
and you guys i see you go you guys going
back when the back and forth when the
news was announced right
and one thing i thought was very
striking when they were giving the
reasoning behind the destiny content
vote the game is getting too big right
all these technical things blah blah
blah blah
and you eloquently said
i don't believe them
i did a single sentence i don't believe
them yeah that's no believe so again i'm
not gonna act like i'm a developer here
you know i'm not gonna try to defend
you know bungie
stuff i don't really know either right
but i gotta get you on this like why do
you feel strongly that
maybe they are not being forthright with
the technical aspects of this reasoning
for the destiny content volume yeah i
don't believe them either by the way
on this one well i mean if you go down
further in that thread it's a little bit
more nuanced i like to sometimes be a
little uh i like to punch the argument
in the mouth a little bit just so that
you guys make sure you're listening
really on the internet is that i know
um but yeah when i say i don't believe
them i think it's more along the lines
of i don't believe that there is no
avenue with which they could be either
correcting their platform building
something on the the back end or solving
this for the consumers
without lopping off stuff that they have
bought and you know you're constantly
here you can't just throw money at it
you can't just throw people at it that's
not that's all fine and i understand how
maybe their platform is broken um
the spaghetti code of tiger engine what
about that
whatever your issues might be
whether or not i believe them i want to
hear it at a fundamental level
it's not my problem
you sold me a product if it doesn't work
uh i'm very i'm very sympathetic to your
excuses what you do is hard gaming is
hard software engineering is hard i
don't have a problem with that
but you ask me to kind of give your
excuses evangelize them to others no i'm
sorry i'm not going to do that figure it
out and i want to play forsaken
and you're not going to let me do that
and that's you know we're going to have
words that your model is fundamentally
taking advantage of it beer minimum to
people three years ago if you want to
say travis and i kind of agree with this
okay well you're you're on you're on
notice now rick uh i would say yep okay
that's fair they're also for sure
out of me i mean like that's as soon as
it happened i said and i'm not lying
about this i'm like i like destiny but
i'm not i'm not in for this i'm not this
is this is not what i signed up for and
so i won't do it again all right you
know fool me once that's fine
um but yeah i don't believe them because
it doesn't strike me as accurate with
every other piece of information that i
have it does strike me that maybe the
resources would be intense
to fix whatever they've got going on and
that to me is perhaps more honest i'm
the rare i'm the rare guy on the
internet that would actually probably
prefer the message it's like look guys
we got to make money on this we need to
feed our families um so
it would take x amount of man-hours we
don't want to do that this we thought
was the middle road chances are rick
hogue likes that messaging more um
doesn't work for most
um
i don't even think it's about money
don't believe it yeah i don't think it's
money and i don't believe the technical
excuse either i really think it's about
splitting the player base they've got
this monster game and they've got 50
activities you can be in and they can't
keep 50 playlists active it's like when
servers go offline when in a multiplayer
game when it's been out for like six
years right like it when that happens
you have to turn off the servers because
there's not enough players to keep that
playlist and i think
the the expansion like how many how many
for sake you got the patrol zone you got
any activities like if you're doing uh
yeah
or the the two activities the baron
yeah um
like nothing i would definitely say
though like
one of the reasons they're probably
getting rid of it is because it is under
utilized right now it's probably one of
the reasons it's not being used so when
you say splitting the player blaze
you have new players potentially coming
in
that are going to experience a really
good story and then they'll probably
going to fall into play because we don't
we can't even replay them right now so
they play it once it's not like they're
like i'm going to go do these baron
fights you know or whatever and we have
like ten different businesses i am
constantly onboarding characters by the
way yeah i believe that um but that's
kind of what takes me into kind of my
whole thoughts on this thing is you have
new players
in six months that are gonna miss out on
as hoax said one of the best stories and
like literally pieces of content that
we've ever had in the game now dreaming
city stays i get that the raid stays and
the dungeon is there cool but those are
even going to be more out of context
when the forsaken story isn't there you
also was already here it was already
weird like the new light's like sorry
here's the fast and furious guy and now
here's the universe cool this is about
what you got to go into but at least
what we have the connection to mara now
we have you know crow aldrich all of
those pieces of what's going on
which seem to be very important going
forward by the way like going into which
queen it probably would be good to know
who all these people are that are gonna
leave right when you need to play that
new expansion
you're like hey you got on game pass oh
cool you got this thing you played it
for a little while i hope you played it
but i think the other piece that bugs me
the most about all of this is that
they're charging money for it at all
right now and i'm waiting for that yeah
this is the part that bugs me the most
like
if you're on steam or any store it
should say will be free it should be a
plastered warning something and again
business model they don't want to do
that because if some schmuck goes in and
doesn't listen to a podcast or look at a
bunch of blog they don't know it's going
to be free in two months but if they
figure it out later they're going to be
not free
yeah go on it's going to be free in
december and then
yeah free in december and then gone in
six months and said hey this content
will be leaving here and again pr move
would be the smart way to say hey now
that we announced this is going away you
got friends who haven't played it go get
it for free everybody can play this
thing because then it will go away at
least that would give them
kind of a decent leg to stand on i still
hate that it's going away because it's
so important to what story is going to
be going forward especially as we are
building into a good story for sake
understanding this stuff and not having
to go watch a bite video no offense
amazing videos but like if it's sitting
there in the game yeah it's like if it's
sitting there in the game and you can go
experience the forsaken campaign see
what aldrin went through trying to do
all this stuff for his sister and then
basically screws up everything we've got
now and all of those pieces the
interactions that you miss
you like they're they're gonna be so out
of touch when it comes to witch queen a
new player is gonna be like well this
person looks cool but why are we here
who's mara what's crow doing
you don't think they already will though
with all the seasonal stuff like so much
has happened in the past
that's seasons week-to-week stories that
isn't going to make sense to you like
even if you played it makes sense to me
i can tell you that watching my brother
play and i was like wait what is what
does osiris do wait i don't know yeah
if you play forsake him
and then shadow keep and then uh beyond
beyond light and then you go straight to
witch queen the
beyond light the witch queen will not
make sense to you there's no way that
you like kill aramis and you're like
cool or you freeze aramis and then
you're like wait now there's all these
new characters and somebody died and
there's like a little that's right as we
talked about in the last week there
needs to be depending on what you've
missed like the timeline and then each
timeline you can go through play even if
it's just like the inkblot storyboard
cinematics that we kind of keep
mentioning however they want to do those
because those are probably a little
lower budget
do something like that to explain how we
got to where we are so somebody can at
least some see something in game that's
visually presented in kind of a nice
easy you don't have to go read books of
text
um
it preferably at least um and you could
be like hey if you want to see more you
could have the option you could have
lore books hopefully they keep if they
like vault lore books like what the hell
but but overall i would say like go in
and like come out of your physical
library yeah
like hey what have you missed like the
seasonal content for last year like
what's drifter's story have you seen any
of those interactions they need to have
those little things that you need to
interact with in the game and if that
stuff isn't there going into witch queen
it's even harder and harder because we
know there's three more years of this
franchise and it's making it harder and
harder for anyone to jump in and not be
completely lost especially for somebody
like you who wants to at least
experience the story you'd love to have
some backstory
by school but you'd much probably rather
have it in game if you could
it's super it's super weird and and this
is from someone that had played enough
to at least have a
grounding to go through the onboarding
process right now and and get to that
screen where it's just here's the eight
boxes in this on the side and then i i'm
like i don't even know what the game
wants me to do yeah isn't it
i just want to see the story
isn't it crazy hope that you've you said
you've played this game for hundreds of
hours and and you're a casual yeah you
play yeah
and you don't even get to know what's
going on in the story you you get people
will laugh at you when you say you
played hundreds of hours because they'll
be like come on that's like you're not a
real destiny player i'm like what
no it's it's an amateur
my understanding of things going on
there's a crystal and some moths like i
it's like yeah all good
imagine that for imagine that for any
other game imagine if you told your
friends yeah i played like 400 hours of
the witcher 3 and they were like wow
casual you need to really play that game
like you probably don't even know what's
happening you'd be like
like what yeah no well maybe it needs a
witcher journal maybe you know i was
hopeful when i saw that they added that
timeline i was like oh they could do
something right there and then it was
mostly i think they will they have to
they've got to do it
they have to add something in game to
catch people up because it's crazy
real quick to gaming forte with the five
dollar super chat question we lose the
single player campaign but keep the raid
last time i checked the campaign led up
to the raid seems like a middle ground i
don't think anybody's argued that
keeping that dreaming city like one of
everybody's favorite destinations is a
bad thing like having the dungeon having
the dreaming city still the secrets in
there but even we disagree that it
builds up through the kids i yeah i mean
you can you go from the tangled shore to
the dreaming city you actually like
enter the destination
yeah yeah you go to it but the raid is
about like you fighting a dragon and it
has kind of nothing to do that's still
sabbath who was actually causing you
know that's the whole thing that caused
crow to or aldrin i should say to kind
of do what he did
anyway but the idea is like now what
you're saying forte i was gonna say you
lose the single campaign you lose the
connection to this raid the raid now is
even more out of context kind of the way
the leviathan was like unless you did
the one
uh what were they called
like the one little like side mission
that basically ever mentioned callus we
all went to the raid we're like hey
here's this big giant gold ship what the
hell is this patrol it was a patrol yeah
whatever it was and it was um and we're
all going
oh no it was an adventure that's what it
was adventure yes oh yeah
but i was like unless you knew that like
you go to callus and you're going
okay i have no idea why we're here it's
cool and shiny but again and now again
same thing's gonna happen last wish very
cool raid fun mechanics one of the
coolest examples to actually go through
for a destiny raid if you actually get
through it it's a hell of an experience
but again why are we here i don't know
if you're a new player and that's the
hard part
i wanted to um again have some fun with
a hog and start trouble oh
what i was gonna say is uh about
let's let's put ourselves in that in the
mindset let's get let's get our
corporate car going for a little bit
let's put ourselves in the mindset of
bungie so all right
bungee financial hats here we go but i
mean some of the cowboys accuse me of
this so i think it's funny so i might as
well just play into this but um
what i was going to say is like what do
you say you actually mentioned one of my
thought process of why they i think
they're doing this right in your video
what if
part of this because like i said you
eloquently say tango shore
high moon studios helped on that right
yeah
what if part of this is
we are suddenly slowly disconnecting all
activision assisted content one right
two
what about they say okay
from a cohesion point because in
fairness
if some new player comes into the game
right it's we all know the onboarding is
terrible let's just call it what it's
not good you don't know really what's
going on but one of the more egregious
things in my opinion is obviously the
progression of the crow character from
aldrin to crow but then if you're
playing and you go into the tango show a
spider is and you see
him there when he should be in the helm
so there's that disconnect okay why is
some people mentioning him here and then
when i play tangled shore he's this
character but then over here he's
somewhere else so from a narrative
cohesion standpoint you know that's
another reason then the third reason
like i think what um travis was saying
which was like okay let's just say they
because we know bungie are very analytic
driven right they're very data driven
so what if they're like look we're
looking at all the destinations which i
don't know how nessus survives this but
kengo shore
is by far the least populated zone in
our metrics right and they come together
and say all this stuff spiders and
spider has this little like
right right he's the he's the broker
today you go there okay what's the
what's the exchange ray on the on the
sean
currently exchange on the japanese
market it's early it's 2 a.m okay
exactly exactly he's there's the voice
actor from gears award uh mark's he's
amazing but um so what if they look at
those three things and say yeah these
are really the reasons why activision
play account narrative thing
with those three things does hulk still
hold that stairs like yo
i don't care
absolutely cog
yeah so here here's the thing right so
you have these conversations online i i
understand being a fan of something and
i don't have a problem with people you
know backing up destiny or bungie on
these things i i get how that can happen
um if you're in the 90 let's say you
know you are in the 98 and they say
there's two percent of people that enjoy
the tangled chore we're not going to
worry about you i think that's fine from
an analytical perspective if that is in
fact the case i
am not in the 98
so i can only speak from my experience
um and i i say okay that's fine then you
don't care about me that's okay i don't
care about you uh you know i mean it
isn't an emotional response there it's i
i disagree with this model these are the
kinds of things i like i like your
campaign content that should never go
away i like the vault idea in terms of
letting me play it separately um in
terms of the narrative they have they
have the smallest bits of lines around
their ui in their menus suggesting that
when you go and play forsaken it's a
it's a memory
um i can't i can't remember what it it's
uh it's like a dream sequence or
something yeah like
simulation even like you could do
something like it might be it might say
simulate i remember like clicking
through it being like it's you know this
is this is old uh i was like that's fine
um so i think if you could you could do
better with that and say you know this
is this is how this happened i mean like
look
you play forsaken and you're like oh the
blue the blue guy is super bad that's a
bad guy right there um and that's like
where you're set up he's freaking thanos
for that campaign right and i love that
uh but yeah when you're otherwise
getting messages when you're not playing
forsaken and like whatever current
destiny is you're like well he's
he's like i don't know he's like a han
solo type now i don't i don't know what
the hell is happening with him so
and again i kind of missed beats between
shadow and and and beyond light so it's
like he's good he something happened in
there um and
yet i think we're
mostly capable of being like that's a
cool story you don't get confused
watching one of the star wars is out of
order and saying i don't understand how
those other ones work together you say
okay yeah this is old i can handle that
from a narrative perspective i think the
analytics is probably where the closest
is i know i mentioned the activision
thing because it was so obvious and
forsaken
when you read those articles and it's
bungie did the dreaming city and hymon
did the rest and it's like oh what
survived huh and it's like yeah okay all
right okay that's so i mean i'm not sure
that there's somebody that said this is
a perfect way to do it and hey it just
happens to be this way as well i don't
really think it's driving them that way
you don't kill good content just because
you didn't like your former partners uh
but
i think the data is probably right you
see it in multiple of their blog posts
that say you know whatever war mind is
.3
and it's five percent of our size i
think they said at one point
and so
i i get it i get how you can get there i
think it's massively disrespectful to
the people that got you to the place
where your game is as popular as it is
um and
i also understand that i am not the only
person in the marketplace and i'm not
maybe even emblematic of the modern
marketplace and so far as if i go to
that raid and i see the fat guy in the
golden ship i am not as enthused about
it if i don't understand the ins and
hows and what wise this is all happening
versus i think a lot of people are not
me and it's got cool mechanics and it
looks cool and there's a fat guy to kill
i don't do you kill him at the end see i
don't play raids anyway
kind of it's hard
to explain
he's a robot
so i think a lot of people can be
engaged with the situation as just
presented as almost a just a metaphor
you know it's just games and cool and
you're jumping through hoops and you're
doing that kind of thing i don't have
any problem with that um but just like
i'm not the guy that's playing the arena
shooters if i'm not why are we why are
we fighting why is this a medieval
castle and this is a science fiction
spaceship i don't why is this all
happening that isn't
that that isn't what i like i like to
have a world and that's why you know
final fantasy 14 is probably a better
fit for me than what destiny is doing
right now even though i'm more inclined
generally speaking to like space wizards
and and science fiction um then
what 14 is doing which i haven't gotten
far enough i again gets good at 200
hours or whatever right um so it's way
too much work
you know
yeah so cog you asked me does it make
does it change my mind no because i'm
still me
um and that doesn't convince me and i
don't care what your analytics show if i
bought forsaken and i can't play it now
which yeah
isn't convincing anybody in the bungee
board room that's fine
but i can only i can only advocate for
my consumer
experience of course absolutely
guys
i was going to say one thing real quick
shout out to addicts with the two dollar
super chat he just said hoga is wrong
and i just got here literally all attic
said so adding a message
but just kidding at the end yeah
yeah
no shout out what's up man um good job
oh i'm sorry no travis yeah i was just
going to be devil's advocate one more
time uh to this conversation because i
think that
there's sometimes this
i i would i would i would describe it as
like a uh
an inaccurate kind of description that
games are becoming more it's more
anti-consumer friendly because of the
seasonal model and because of uh games
as a service and that sort of thing
which is something i i disagree with um
i i think that the old model of like you
buying a game and you feeling like you
own it and having it on this even though
you don't own it because of drm but like
you know you you feel like you own it
because you have the disc and you can
play at any time uh
that that model it it had
some good things about it like your
ability to resell it or your ability to
you know have it and put it in your tray
any time you want but it also had a lot
of things that weren't good for the
consumer
uh the fact that the the cost was pretty
high the barrier of entry was high the
cost is much lower in the games of
service era with stuff like game pass if
destiny continues to be on game pass in
the future the expansions go away as
kind of a barrier of entry and then
you're just playing things over the time
but i think there's room for both right
there's room for games where you like
you buy it and you own it and hogue will
go and buy and play those games and i'm
sure they will continue to make those
games forever because there's clearly a
market for it and i would say
playstation kind of owns that market
right now like they are that's where
they put all their focuses and those
games where you you play them you enjoy
the story and then you put it in a box
until you want to play it again later
but there's also a market for the
reverse right there's a market for
people who want that low barrier of
entry and want something that grows and
evolves over time and has content that
they can play every week and
you're probably right you have a lot of
introspection in terms of like that's
not for me and that's totally fine
i think there's room for both but i
think the idea that like one model is
bad or uh predatorial is is just
inaccurate and that sometimes comes up
in this conversation the caveat here is
that i do agree most people bought
forsaken thinking that they'd be able to
play it forever right and that that i
would say going forward nobody thinks
that and i think the way that bungie
describes in their terms user agreement
they describe everything as live content
i actually agree i think that that's
true like nobody plays destiny and
thinks like oh it's going to be like
this forever because your favorite gun
can get nerfed or they can take it out
of the game they've done that before or
make it so that you basically can't play
it um and and that's content that you
paid for in a sense but the idea of you
owning things in a live service game is
sort of
you know that's not it's not really how
it works and nor should it because the
game is evolving and changing all the
time and sometimes they take stuff away
from you to balance the sandbox or yada
yada um and i think that's sort of just
something that people have to
know what they're getting into and i
think the industry can do a lot better
in distinguishing what type of game it
is right like bungie should destiny
should almost have like a live tag
attached to it so that when you play it
you know that
everything is subject to change that
said that rick on the cover he lost
not you not for you stay away yeah yeah
i still i still think it applies to the
old model of doing it too not completely
offline games like the super nintendo
but even today you can buy a game and
they can remove content that they've
removed episodes from tv shows because
of content that they found to be
offensive and you can't watch that
anymore unless you own the discs so this
is like a
this is a worldwide thing it's even not
even really contained but see those
people who bought the discs actually
still can go watch them
yeah i actually went and bought discs of
some of my favorite comedy shows because
there was a you know pc uh thing
recently where they were taking taking
episodes down and i was like well the d
d episode of community you can't watch
online anymore because that's offensive
and that's the best episode of the show
i was like i'm gonna go buy that
by that season so um yeah and i i
totally i empathize with with what
you're saying hog in terms of
it's unfortunate but i don't think it's
the only model well you started this
with devil's advocate i have to say this
is why i like talking to you travis i i
don't fundamentally disagree with
anything that you said in in the
macroscope there i i think that was very
insightful to say
different products are for different
people and what i really like is i
completely agree with the notion of if
you look at how much it costs to play
something if you want to entertain
yourself with a video game it has never
been easier whether you want to pop into
fortnite or warframe or a dollar thing
on your phone there are so many
ridiculous values for people out there
right now i do think that you can get
predatorial in any model whether you're
selling it
originally or whether you're free to
play and doing something else so talk
about the ubisoft model but yeah
i i jokingly tell people it's like i'm
the stupidest person i love ubisoft so i
buy them day one i like i like to
support them but it's like that i bought
far cry 6. that game is going to be like
30 next month i mean like that's just
what they do they put it on sale on
black friday for like the micro
transactions kill me in those games and
you know but i but i like those games
and so yeah absolutely that's that's its
own version of an idiot tax so that's
fine
um but no i i fundamentally agree with
you that it can support different models
and and one of the things i like to do
in virtually the reason i read through
end user license agreements the reason i
talk so often about how stupid
it is that streamers do what they do
when they don't have the license to do
it not because you're going to get
killed at any given day but because
you're making your livelihood on this
kind of thing go go put pressure on
these folks to give you the license to
freaking stream things
that
transparency i think solves a lot of
these problems if if destiny is selling
itself as fortnight and forsaken is an
event that you want to participate in
while it's available um even if it had
some kind of ticket component like
you're doing something where you have to
actually pay the money to participate
that to me reads differently and the
more people that can know that the
better and i think you're right you know
the second vault here should be a pretty
big notice um bungie's being stupid
about selling things for an extra month
i i don't know why but yeah that's
ridiculous we all agree in terms of
notice transparency is always what i'm
about i i had somebody come to my
comments the other day and i i think it
was talking about this the vault concept
i said well i thought you were four
contracts uh rick how can you complain
about this this is just bungie being
capitalistic i was like well okay so i'm
for freedom of contract and that's great
i'm for people being able to enter into
the stupidest contracts they want to i'm
also capable of calling out what i think
are stupid contracts and telling you hey
look bungie has a sentence in here that
says we can revoke your virtual currency
at any time
that's that's super weird i mean i
actually paid you ten dollars for
whatever it is that v bucks the
equivalent is in destiny and bungie
could tomorrow say no actually that's
zero it's like uh before
they've converted our currencies before
not silver but other stuff
one of the things that happens in these
terms and conditions is and this is
where a lot of parentheticals come from
if you've ever kind of watched them
evolve is they respond after the fact to
issues that were brought up and they had
to refund somebody or somebody had a
problem with it or the better business
bureau was called so you start to get
little tweaks oh by the way we meant
this and we meant this and we meant this
so
i like to point out what you're agreeing
to not to tell you you can't
i can editorialize as i did in this
video and say i think it's a bad model
but if you want to do it as long as you
understand your eyes are wide open i'm
never going to say you shouldn't do that
that's you that's your values that's
what you like if you love destiny you're
okay with all this go for it i'm out but
that's fine i'm a guy
i feel respectfully respectful
can i ask you a question before we move
on to yeah one last one two yeah oh you
go first then then i'll wrap it up
because mine's sort of unrelated okay
yeah last one i had was just um from a
solution standpoint the thing that we
saw e uh trending during this whole
period was destiny three yep and i
wanted to get your thoughts process
because this one
has this is a big split and a lot of i
don't want to be disrespectful casual
destiny players or people who do only a
couple hundred hours right
now
you gotta have at least a thousand to be
considered reasonable in this game you
gotta pump those numbers up those are
rookie numbers those are rookie members
i would actually want to go look at my
how much i've played a destiny in my
like my my gamertag i'm gonna check but
a lot of people were saying you know i
don't understand this is like a good
reason why they should just drop the two
make three
and then alleviate the issues but then
the flip side people were saying well
you're still back at the same thing you
know so you're still gonna you know back
where you started and content has to be
built again so like where are you at
with that because clearly they've made a
decision once to split from activision
which was surprising to me in ee and
travis which was like yo we're gonna
stay here in this world we're staying
we're iterating
you know i mean here's by the way
lightfall
final shape and all these other
expansion names that we're hearing that
this thing is going to continue to go on
so like where are you at with the
destiny 3 divide in the community
so i
don't think i articulated this in my own
video but when i see the scenario as
presented and giving bungie the full
benefit of the doubt this is just a
technic technological impasse we can't
do anything except lop off the front to
make this work basically we can support
a hundred gigs or a hund a little north
of 100 gigs and we're going to have to
keep kind of managing around that
my honest feeling was
the the right move from a consumer basis
is to start working on destiny 3 and a
platform that is actually what you want
it to be
and to shift when that's done and to and
to move people over there and i don't
know what that cost looks like and i
know the reason you don't do that from a
business perspective is you're
independent now you need that roi you
can't afford the risk of the people
don't come with
yep and i get that i am not
i'm not blind to the corporate answers
and how that boardroom looks and what
the financial folks are saying about
these questions i just come at the
internet from a very specific
perspective i'm a corporate lawyer most
people expect me to just go with
whatever the entities are saying i look
at it and say no i can fully understand
where they're coming from we are not on
the same side of this question you you
are not bungee you don't have shares in
bungie i don't think unless unless you
know no i don't you do so you know hey
but we're on different sides of this
question so
let's look at it from that perspective
so i look at it and say i think your
platform's fundamentally broken as far
as i can tell what you've announced to
the world is you're gonna have to keep
doing this so if you bought shadow
keeper you bought beyond light or you
bought witch queen ultimately that
product we're trying to sell you three
years from now
then it's not going to be yours anymore
regardless of whether it's the best
thing since sliced bread so i look at
that and say
you guys
wanted to and did i'm hearing from
imbalances i'm hearing from other folks
and saying they're getting there with
story like it's working
it feels good i don't know that much
because i like i said crystal moth
that's what i got
but
if that is the case
this model is like fundamentally wrong
for that i can agree with travis that
fortnight makes sense because nobody
really cares when the comet hit or when
troy baker showed up as a spy or what
whatever we're fighting superman and
it's all good now but
if you're going to tell this story and
you want to watch those twists and turns
you want to live you know
he was aldrin when i knew him and i
think i've heard you use the word crow
so i'm going to use that and try to
sound really on top of it he is now
chrome and he's a guardian by the way
he's also a moth crystal yes yes
no but aldrin
is actually a guardian though that's uh
crow is a guardian he is
okay all right well this is good to know
i'll get on the i'll get on the byf
channel i'll i'll figure this all out
but
uh that if that's your goal and i love
that goal
i can't get past that you can't give me
your money
shut up where is he i was on the byf
channel it's life
often that's why you got to come back so
we can get you out of these tropes oh
yes well if you ever need the dumb guy
that has no idea what's happening i'm
happy i'll call my brother
i would actually prefer him to stay with
his level of knowledge because it's like
it's like a test case we could have we
don't need right
questions
we want you to explain what's happening
nothing yeah no
space monster space monkey i'm sorry ape
yeah gorilla so but i think i put in my
video right i put a picture of breaking
bad up and i said it's like trying to
follow a really great story when you lop
off the first two seasons
and it's not the same and you can go
watch somebody you know give you a
summary of the first two seasons of
breaking bad or whatever
it's not the same it's not internal to
the product
and frankly i think forsaken is great i
don't want to see it go because i like
it and i've actually played through it
three times in three years i mean it's
the kind of thing that i do go back to
it's not that long and it's a it's a lot
of fun
so i look at it as a loss and they don't
and and i believe me i you probably know
this running a destiny you know podcast
i've got some animated folks in my
comments to that video
they are very
they're very upset at me
um you know i've talked about
international antitrust law that got
people less upset i had tim sweeney
directly yelling at me on twitter he was
less upset
than the destiny fans just to be clear
so i mean like and that's fine i i think
engendering that kind of passion is
actually really super cool even if it's
not coming from me i i like that i like
that there are people that feel that way
about products
but
i can only call it like i see it i'm not
lying to you when i say this is how i
feel about the model
model
i think everyone agrees even destiny
fans
yeah so i mean that's that's where i'm
at and then what uh travis you you
wanted the the last
michael my question was just a question
i forgot to ask you during the intro
video which is what's your favorite
supreme court case and why and maybe we
can exchange i have a favorite obviously
everyone's got a favorite supreme court
we're going to be a little bit off
target for a second everybody i'm gonna
make note here hold on timestamp of 118.
at least by this you gotta ask this
everyone's got a favorite court case
this feels like uh the our longest
running segment of helping
yeah our new longest running segment
what's your favorite it's not like
what's your favorite cookie what's your
favorite sandwich what's your favorite
it is fitting for our guests
some of us american history buffs have a
favorite supreme court case my favorite
supreme court case especially for
explaining
current jurisprudence is a case by the
name of wickard v filburn
which was the case shortly after the new
deal cases that helped establish
that
growing your own wheat was interstate
commerce because you didn't buy
interstate wheat
and by
contributing to that growth of the
interpretation of the interstate
commerce led to congress basically being
able to do whatever it wanted in the
united states starting in the early 20th
century um so that's a case that i
actually have a video on check it out on
virtually gowdy if you're interested in
wicked v filburn youtube.com
will actually watch this because
that is a fantastic plug by the way
check it out on virtual legality hoe
glob
radio voice i think that's actually my
dumb corporate messaging voice i have to
look into it um yeah so i actually
occasionally and some people like this
some people don't so i primarily have
virtually allowed to talk about what i
think are important interpretive legal
questions through the lens of pop
culture right like so i'm bringing
legal questions through hey is
spider-man coming back to the mcu how
did that negotiation work with sony what
is scarlett johansson saying about her
that kind of stuff um but i also when
there's big supreme court cases
especially if i get pinged by a thousand
people i'll do that so i just covered
like the supreme court's uh rejection of
an injunction and temporary stay on sb8
but the texas law um so i did that i
generally done a state
i generally cover a lot of um the more
evocative supreme court decisions i
covered some of the the election
lawsuits um and yeah i have what i call
a supreme court series i think we're at
like nine or ten videos of that it's a
it's a smaller audience uh and one of
those was wicked v filburn where i where
i talked about well
they can't always get it right and so uh
that's that's my favorite historically
yeah and i don't know that a lot of
people share that one my favorite is nyx
v headen
uh because that was the um
the 1893
uh the one that said that when it comes
to u.s customs a tomato can be defined
as a vegetable even though it's fruit
yes because
that was yeah a guy a guy basically was
saying i don't have to pay your taxes on
vegetables because i am shipping
tomatoes and there was a very long
stream of court cases that eventually uh
led to the supreme court saying uh you
knew what we meant and i really like
that from my legal by legalizing that
from time to time yes and it actually
actually
it actually sets a pretty good legal
precedent that the law should work as it
uh as it is was intended to not that way
people aren't picking over the words and
trying to find loopholes and that sort
of stuff that sometimes the supreme
court could just be like don't don't do
that don't try to pull that loophole on
us and and uh yeah
because it's got seats inside
it's so petty it's such a petty case but
it has big ramifications i like that a
lot i'm talking about wheat growing so
we got it we got the agriculture uh yeah
we got it
i think there's a lot of history of
agriculture in this country or something
now if we can we've got carbs we've got
vegetables now if we can just get
something over protein if you got a
about pregnant cows are you kidding me i
could go on and on how much law do you
want
okay
give me give me 60 seconds on the
pregnant cows because then we're going
to have a whole meal of law here so this
is going to be perfect well i'm going to
remember the specifics here but suffice
to say it was can a contract exist where
somebody thinks the cow is pregnant and
the other party doesn't think it's
pregnant it's more valuable if it's
pregnant and so it's a question of
meeting in the minds in a contractual
dispute and whether or not the guy that
thought he sold the baron cow actually
sold a p pregnant cow can get it back
cows that's crazy
cows
what is the value of the people
every kind of food
but there's just a legal case about
whether subway bread was bred
i think i do remember that it was not
much sugar yep really oh too much sugar
in the bread i do remember don't even
get me started on the tuna
no it's just i don't think it actually
has enough like grain or flour i think
it's actually whether it's sugar high
fructose sugar and then there's a
there's a there's like an fda definition
um so i i'm i'd be lying to you cog if i
said i could pull up from memory
specifics yeah okay
there's a similar there's similar stuff
right now with the impossible meat can
they call it the impossible the the the
not milk can it be called milk if it's
if it's soy all that stuff like there's
a lot of traction against first
amendment consideration so you're also
getting pushback from there was a case
in california about um non-dairy
uh butter that was made out of whatever
it was vegan butter and whether or not
you could call it butter because it has
an assumption of dairy it was a whole
thing oh and the dairy industry is out
there just trying to crush these people
you can't call it milk it's not like
they're just silly it's nut juice just
let that roll off your tongue
they
the meat lost does not want does not
want impossible meat to be able to call
it meat they're like upset about it
they're out there with the lawyers i'm
serious dude it's crazy
not lying
beyond beef and impossible meat no
there's another one too it's like little
things that you notice have you next
time you go to
the grocery everybody likes ice cream
well notice if you go look at ice cream
it's either ice cream or frozen dairy
dessert and it all depends on how much
like water or actually milk fat is in
there so depends on are you getting like
real ice cream you're getting like a
slightly less whipped variety like
that's one of those random things that
i've noticed as well so
are you getting a forsaken campaign or
are you getting a games as a service
full circle
transparency is key and for me is like
i'm gonna go full circle and just say
like just the fact that like tell people
what's going on if i go to the xbox
store right now it says 24.99 for it and
i can still pay it in two months it's
free that's just wrong
in my opinion so something that is good
though on xbox if you go to buy forsaken
it'll tell you
also on game pass
it almost encourages you not to buy it
okay fine yeah go to the playstation
store go to steam that's more like i
said
yeah there you go there you go but there
are some good practices out there where
they're trying to like not trick you
into buying something twice which i
think is cool we've come full circle on
the dcv and all that we really
really had a giant detour made it back
somehow
it's all connected guys yeah
so
hope you stick with us as long as you
want we're going to jump into at this
point uh the festival's out of my depth
before get ready folks absolutely
we're going to jump into this week and
that is going to be the festival of the
lost so this is the halloween of the
event in destiny
previously we were dealing with stuff
like oh i don't know the haunted forest
and things of that nature
which were taking place on mercury which
is now gone which goes back to what we
were talking about so back no i'm just
kidding um but this year festival lost
launched eva levante's back with all of
her eververse transactions and tess is
ranking in the dough for
so many different things we have a
spider sparrow that actually crawls when
you're standing still which some people
have seen which kind of freaks them out
um
but before we go too far into this new
rad brought something to my attention
and i wanted to point this out what's
going on bungie so the big thing i saw
the tweet yeah
i saw this and i about lost my mind um
so
the main purpose of what you're doing in
festival lost this time is you're trying
to build up this lore book of kind of
all these people of the lost
and what you're doing is you're going
into normal activities and you're
getting spectral pages which are like
these green looking ones and then you're
going to go into the haunted sectors
playlist which i think there's like
three lost sectors in there you'll go
through you'll shoot the guys with the
glowing purple heads kind of headless
horseman night things and then you'll
like get the pages that are spectral to
manifest and then you go back in the
tower and put them into the book this is
the big grind outside of trying to get
the weapon of this event most people are
working on that
the spectral pages of course like
anything people are going to try and be
efficient that's what always happens in
these things we're going to get back to
the grindy section of destiny people
want to be efficient about it
now i did a video on tuesday probably
the best way to find it wednesday i did
an updated one because i wouldn't i post
something on twitter and i'm like hey
this is pretty fast i don't think i've
ever been corrected faster
that i was so wrong they're like oh this
is faster and this is faster and this
could be another thing and this but it's
like oh i've done that faster too
so i was wrong so i made a new video to
correct that one
bungie just threw both of those in the
trash
um they said a change has been deployed
to limit spectral pages and candy
rewards in rathborn hunts which was one
of the fastest to do solo even faster
the group expunge missions which i was
doing in about three and a half minutes
with the titan and lake of shadows which
people were burning through they that
strike which isn't going anywhere is
still one of the fastest people abuse
the nightfall change will be reverted
next tuesday so pretty much the most
efficient methods on all of these things
that people are trying to and you need
194 spectral pages to finish the whole
book and then you have to convert the
194 but to get the 194 like expunge you
would get five
yeah so you still had to do a lot of
them
that's awful yeah you still have to do
what 39 of them if i'm doing bad math
i'm doing i'm doing public events that's
like that yeah public events who get two
to three
strikes you'll get
four three to four
and then i was like oh that's not bad
and people are like oh you got expunged
rathborn hunts they're dropping five i
was like okay rathborn hunts were like
five to six
yeah no so this wow
so i mean it sucks we'll get to what's
going on with festival in a second but
the fact that they just took the most
efficient method
like you know it's seven o'clock on a
thursday night and said nope
i wanted to kind of get my um at least
fellow
fellow players and then hogue somebody
like you as well when you you hear about
something like this that hey there's an
efficient way to do it bungie just
knocks that down
what what goes through your head is this
some you're just like i really don't
care about this now what do you do in
that situation i'm curious
i i still have the season i bought so
we'll see i i was going to ask the
question that i didn't know the answer
to which is how long is the event three
weeks
four three yeah i thought we're gonna
have oh yeah four weeks i think three
more after does it go past halloween
yeah a little bit
goes past november into november yeah uh
october 2 12 through november 2nd so
basically you have to play the game a
lot yeah as tweaked we don't know how uh
how tweaked it will be how how long
in time do we think that is that's
generally how i judge my reasonability
on these kinds of things
how long in time for like wait how many
weeks how long today i think he's asking
how long does it take to finish the book
i think it's like oh it'll probably take
like maybe 10 15 hours of grinding if
you do
the current most efficient method but i
think the reason they nerfed these
methods is because people were getting
that number down quite a bit they're
getting it down to like seven or eight
hours and i think they want they want
this to be stretched over like three or
four weeks where you're playing every
single uh day for you know a couple
hours and eventually you finish it but
uh it is a lot of grinding i'll let the
real players answer the question but i
guess my my
my initial reaction as opposed is
i don't understand exactly once you've
sold the season once they're players
that you're not an mmo you don't need a
monthly subscription fee
why does bungie do this why why do they
care for their hardest of hardcore to
get it in a week i'm not fully
understanding
i think it has to do with uh player
activity they want to get that user
engagement they really care about
engagement and i think it also you know
the more people are in the game the more
they're buying the micro transactions
festival of the lost and all the the uh
the events that happen the live service
events are like basically just uh
pinatas for bungie to to do fundraisers
for
the next content they're doing and uh
they gotta get people on and then and
then they they sell them a bunch of
emotes and stuff better that they're i
mean it works well for them yeah okay
i think that's what it comes down to
yeah it's probably the more time that
you're in game or logging in the
multiple times that you log in you might
check the eververse store
whatever it is pops up you go in there
to get an engram you see the store
probably a statistical number of times
that you log in or do this thing that
you have an interaction with the store
that leads you to buy something you know
they'll work down all the funnels and
figure out what that number is but i'm
sure that's
it has to be it's literally nothing but
engagement at that point because you
have people playing rathborn hunts
expunge missions and nightfall strikes
which are some of it's old but it's all
this season it's not like they're
playing and it's like they want to shove
you back into strikes crucible and
gambit i'm sure and new red's in there
telling me he did two expunges and got
zero
wow so they literally shut them off they
didn't lower them they shut them off
yeah so now what is the only resources
to gain
dead currency well i mean you can do
crucible matches strikes gambit uh
public events are the main foreign of so
they just eliminated the the the
currency from wow previous seasonal
activities yeah you can go to astral
line and you can get like i mean that
one's probably fine yeah that one that's
a long activity
it's kind of a great you know grinding
but if you're doing it anyway i think
the idea is you get pages as you're just
normally playing destiny i think that's
what they want it to be and they don't
want people going out of their way to
just do an activity they wouldn't
normally do to farm the pages and then
log off as soon as possible they want to
make it like a thing that lasts like the
three or four weeks of course which
which is we all like we all know what
this is the artificial engagement and
you know at the end of the day
it again which compounds with the season
of the loss being
super extended because we know which
queen got delayed so this is we have to
keep them here
or i just don't like the the complete
removal though e that's the point yeah
like you're trying to play right now in
check just to be sure but just to be
sure right yeah but even if it's lowered
still the big question why i don't
understand
the reason behind taking something in
your game that's there
it's not like it's broken
it's just efficient and i guarantee they
just want you to make a new video e
that's all i mean they're literally
gonna go probably make one tonight and
be like giant updated you they messed up
you evil influencers you got some red
arrows
yeah you gotta have an arrow the curve
explosion behind you
no it'd be like this more more like
shoot me in the head yeah zero confirmed
he said expunges and give it anymore
expungement i can't speak to this event
specifically but i can say you know at
least
emotionally psychologically for me
one of the things that happens is yeah
i'll go spend on whatever currency and
game i'm playing if i am
getting a fair amount of utility from it
if i'm in a good mood if i'm in a good
space you the more friction you add you
can pass a point where i i'm i'm in full
kind of screw you mode if i think it's
going past the wet place that i want to
be
so
i don't know what analytics they have
for that kind of psychology presumably
they got lines on boards everywhere
saying here's how
a few more people are going to stay
longer they're going to cover the people
that aren't as likely to buy things
but
i i get very very frustrated when i
think they're trying to
go past my tolerance when i feel like if
i'm putting in enough time i should be
able to fill out whatever your event is
and
i think all games struggle with this to
some extent i was just talking about
this with um
what was it outriders i think where it's
like i'm not the guy that's going to go
and min max it and and beat it in two
days which is what you're worried about
yeah but you have to make it fun for the
guy that's not doing that i still want
to give you money or i did before all of
this avengers has done something similar
recently
yeah
yeah
i still want to be a part of that
process and
it's very difficult for them and i
understand it's a very difficult
prospect of both dealing with the
hardcore people that would laugh at my
200 hours or whatever i have and hey
i'm my money's still good here if you
can convince me to part with it
so i was like for me somebody somebody
from blizzard can never remember where
the hell this quote is from and i feel
it was like when bungie was trying to
work with blizzard to kind of understand
some of the mmo or some of the loot
grind
people are always going to leave your
game
it's the state in which they leave your
game and you mention the psychology of
it this for me is just like
i'm just like frustrated i'm like why do
you have to take something out of it and
they said literally the expunge is no
more
it sounds like most of the old content
is not giving anything like you
literally just somebody wants to go a
random expunge mission now let me do
this i haven't done a while nope i just
got one from a rathborn hunter
and it was dropping five
so it's just
it's a weird artificial push in these
directions that as you say like i'm
gonna finish it at some point how
annoyed am i gonna be when i finish it
is the question is it like hey i could
do it efficiently your average person
does probably go play strikes a lot of
people don't even go to youtube to watch
like the fallout videos or these things
and be like these are the efficient ways
that's like maybe a third of the player
base not the average casual person that
jumps on that has less hours than our
guest even and they're just like hey i
play every so often and you know i play
for the hour week that i get that hour
week's gonna do nothing now
so i was like how are they expected to
even try and debate on finishing this
thing especially as you took away
they may be like hey i don't have a lot
of time let me look this thing up they
go in now they've wasted time looked up
a video gone to do the thing because
it's gonna be the most popular video and
then they're like well it's not dropping
from me am i doing something wrong then
like is the helmet on am i wearing the
masquerade helmet so like you just made
it worse in so many different ways and
it's not necessary
this literally kills me like i picked
the worst time to take two days off
tested
yesterday
i'm not done with it i still have half
of my grind to go i'm like yeah because
i saw what's funny i saw your video and
i could calculate everybody had videos
so i'm like all right i know what to do
once i'm ready playing this friday go
hit this thing efficiently and i'm like
oh i'm not going to be doing any of that
i'm going to be stuck
and not no i'm not i'm going to be
honest now my desire
to do it is like what is it the uh we
got the uh the pulse rifle is it the
forest yeah it's the uh jurassic green
it's a lincoln
type 540 pulse it actually does feel
pretty good because it's not right it's
like darkness before it's a solar
honestly it looks like a dinosaur yeah
it's got a little dinosaur it's
yeah the gun actually has like kind of
the diamonds there's also dinosaur armor
in the game now hogue i'm a giant t-rex
right now with the chicken's head the
chicken's head is for halloween yeah
i like that you're not convincing me but
i do like your own background you didn't
do a good job damn just saying i
don't understand why your your civil
disobedience
yeah the dinosaur armor is live i should
say that that is in the eververse so you
can buy that you can't earn it which
something we all wish you could ever do
but you can't even earn
what if you could even earn like hey you
finish the book you get a discount on it
could they even do something like that
hey you can earn it through you can buy
through bright dust you can buy some
bread technically as a currency
money with tess
yeah oh how original okay
so i mean i'm not
sharing with you she ain't in the
training i like that why she ain't in
the content well why would he figure out
what are you kidding me she's standing
on the window like shoving stuff inside
it yeah she's the she's the banker of
the vault
i feel her file size is too large i feel
that you know
we need she is taking up an entire tab
of the menu that's true i think they
should make that post about they was
thinking about the player right there
he'd put her in the vault and let the
game continue with the other five
monetization models they got going on
if they do put her in the vault it'll be
the vault of glass and she's the final
boss no one can be beaten
nobody can beat that parade
she's been acquiring all that stuff in
bright dust all those years powering her
up more menacing
[Laughter]
he is the boss at the end of lightfall
she strips your light away because you
cannot overcome her her darkness
fenn church replaces the templar yes
in this version of uh
well i should probably officially cover
festival lost in more of a
general aspect not trying to rag on it
quite so hard here but you know i had to
mention that because that literally
literally just came up in the middle of
this and i was just like are you
really okay so
dino armor is live the titan has a t-rex
you've got the hunter which looks kind
of like a raptor i've seen a lot of
memes out there they're hilarious
warlocks triceratops i'm sorry i think
you lost this one you've won some other
cosmetics
i like the dinosaur of triceratops i
always have but i don't think the armor
can't no offense to the designer i think
you did as good as you can with the
animal
but it's like it'd be trying to do a
brachiosaurus on a wart like a long neck
some things just don't transfer in the
helm
it kind of looks cool with the three
horns but doesn't compare to the teeth
on the other ones it just doesn't hold
up
of course
broke dinobots but anyway continue
avalavante's here you're gonna do your
little quest and we've got haunted lost
sectors now it's not like the legend
exotic grind or anything like that you
have a playlist node in the tower and
you're going to jump into the haunted
sector playlist you have three of them
to go through or three options you can
at least jump into
lost sectors are match made so it's
really weird since i've been doing so
many of those solo
um but you jump in and you start
standing on these little zones and then
they spawn a giant
um
purple glowing pumpkin headed night guy
with like you know kind of the night
crossbow and you got to take those guys
out they have a little candy explosion
when you kill them and you have about
four minutes to kill as many as you can
would be what i would normally say but
you have four minutes to kill 10 because
if you kill 10 in the four minutes you
sit there and wait for the timer to
finish
that's crazy
is it broken is it like what's happening
i'm just sitting here it was like a full
minute
yeah i had to wait like 30 seconds 45
seconds and you're just no enemy spawn
no zones appeared no more
like guys to kill until you get to the
boss phase but if you finish it too fast
you
stay still and just chill right there
was like me and two other guys just
sitting there emoting just kind of
chilling
after that then a boss will spawn you'll
kind of do the same thing it's got a
couple damage phases each time you need
a damage phase you kill one of the
pumpkin headed guys he drops little
green pumpkins you throw him to break
the shield and then you um kill the boss
in about three phases everybody's either
using fusion rifles or swords just to
nuke them so they all go pretty quick
uh but the decorations in the lost
sectors are pretty cool so if you play
at least enough of them you'll probably
see
what they did and the other piece is as
i said the jurassic green uh it's
basically a skin of the lincoln green
pulse rifle from like basically the
start of d1 or d2 youtube uh it's a 540
feels pretty good it's a fast rate of
fire solar it's got some good decent
perks on it like rangefire multi-kill
clips one option
uh i think i got like a frenzy something
else i've got a couple decent rolls on
it for sure
okay and then of course you're covered
in yes it's solar oh it's actually a
pretty good spot
um but basically you're covered in of
course cosmetics everywhere you've got a
couple things you can earn by finishing
all these pages so you do any activity
in the game to get the spectral pages
then you take them into the haunted
sectors
you get your manifested pages and you
shove those pages into the book and you
need 194 total so it's a bit of a grind
to do it all but the more pages you put
into the book more
um
the more chances basically more drops
you're gonna see i'll finish one of
those haunted sectors and have killed
like 10 11 or 12 of those headless guys
and i'll see like three of those things
drop and i don't even have that many
pages in there so you're getting a lot
of rolls on this pulse rifle so if you
put some time in you'll get a chance at
a decent pulse rifle and 540 pulses do
feel pretty good right now so it's not
nothing and especially for titans the
solar weapon pairs well with an exotic
we've got right now so you've got some
some benefits to the weapon this time
around it's not for just like it's a
fine weapon it's got a little more to it
question um what's this thing about the
ascendant lens i saw i was about to
bring that up yeah okay they gave a use
you give it to the queen and she rewards
you with a bunch of loot yeah she'll
give you like 23 only
you get three three pulse rifles yep so
yeah you get three you get three rolls
yeah hopefully you get something good if
you if you don't care about the pages
but the pages give you lore and
apparently there's in an in-game
explanation for why the headless ones
with pumpkin heads exist so i'm
interested in doing that that's why like
i hope so we've got the byf video for
this by god gotta go to
just
that's right that's still funny to me
sorry
hello
amazing
dude so
i was gonna say that's most of the
events i know yeah i was going to say
travis i know you've played it cog has
been thinking about it um you guys got
to educate me oh then i'll i'll just
tell you what i think
i am very very glad that they finally
got rid of the uh infinite forest event
that that thing sucked uh and i'm really
glad that it's gone and i like that they
added in in lore explanation for the i
had the headless ones and uh use the
ascendant lens i think that's all really
cool everything else i hate i
hate this event so much uh it's just
lots of grinding they just want you to
play the game and get pages and then you
convert those pages by doing the same
activity over and over again um and i
mean i'm glad that they're trying new
stuff i can't be super hard on it
because the last couple years has been
like
really really awful with this event i'm
just glad that they're trying new stuff
but just in general like these these
live events they just
they never have enough content and what
they do add they just make you play
again and again and again ad nauseum to
hit some like artificial uh bar and and
like hoag said like the whole bar
feeling it's just not for me it's like
the one thing in destiny that i'll
always just i reject it they say fill
this bar and i go no and teddy you know
the taste of the the teddies of the
world they insist on hitting every bar
at max and i'm just like i kind of pick
my battles
but um but with this one i think
i think i might i don't know if i have
time in between reviews to bar fill on
this one but i just these live events
never really
never really capture me they just they
they're so grindy i can't really get on
board with them so
that's where i stand
gotcha eat uh i mean for me
yeah
it's fine
i mean that's like literally it's not a
glowing glowing recommendation it was
right in the middle motivating me to
even try it now
uh
i'm just still disheartened about the
whole swap so now like my thoughts on it
are even more different than they were
literally like two hours ago from when
this thing came out at seven o'clock
um
give it a trick or treat which one is it
give me uh
if you had to rate it trick or treat
right now as of right now trick
yeah i mean because they literally just
tricked us of what we're going to be
grinding for no it's like the dyno armor
is kind of cool um
that's true i'm sure we'll see
i'm sure we'll see the monster armor
later because some people were hoping
for like creature the black lagoon or
dracula or something had some other i
mean of course i always love the skin
cyclops that clubs look terrible that's
why i didn't vote for it for the titan
yeah i was like i wasn't loving that one
um
i don't know i was like i wasn't sure
how they were gonna do the sectors
there's only three of them so it's
limited i like the decorations that they
put in there
i just wish they were more
i guess i wish they were all over the
place
like a bit more it's like the tower
doesn't look cool but it's always just
the middle tower you got three lost
sectors and you're out
but it's like some people someone said
like the lost sectors they're so bright
they don't even feel because the lights
are on and everything it's not like
they're dark like the haunted forest
kind of had that creepy tone it's like
it's like watching a scary movie with
the lights on you know full
and you're over here like oh no the guy
has jumped out at me ah
it's like it's not quite the same
feeling the guys look cool like the
animation on the pumpkin heads are cool
the candy exploding but
i mean you're literally buying masks
that you can do for goofy pictures
you've got dino armor and you've got
lost sectors and when i counted up i was
like 194 of these like let's just like
add the hours to the activities you got
to do which just got longer and then you
got to go and turn run this thing
because i think the max you can do is
like 11 or 12 pages that you get out so
you're gonna have to do
15 of the haunted sector runs if you
want to complete the book and i see some
people finish already i'm like y'all are
crazy um
but it's like it's it's fine the gun
isn't bad i'm actually pleased that the
gun has decent rolls feels good in the
meta right now so i'm kind of happy the
gun has got something to it because
we've had like oh here's an auto rifle
when auto rifles don't feel good that's
not a great moment this one for a pulse
like
i'm actually pleased it feels pretty
good kind of unique little look to it
i'm okay with the weapon it's definitely
not the worst weapon we've had
and some of the cosmetics like the
spider sparrow when you sit there and
kind of chill the legs actually kind of
creepily walk and then when you run the
legs like tuck
and then when you go back to slow speed
like it sits there and walks and i saw
some people just like nope nope nope
like burn the house down for a spider
because it's a big creepy looking spider
i love that thing and then also the
ghosts that is like kind of like a crack
like the glow stick look you'll see kind
of that glowing color there's a shader
you can put on that thing that is
literally like blinding it's just like
it just glows green so somebody messed
with the shader i forgot what that is so
there's some kind of fun stuff to it but
overall i'd say
there's not i think new rad said it
pretty well it's like the haunted forest
the race against the clock the fact that
you weren't limited and the fact that
you hit 10 and you're limited like
you're captain you hit that as a way
that's crazy i can't believe that yeah
see that it doesn't even end the
activity early that's what i would have
done if you don't want them to be able
to grind it at least and the activities
i don't have to stand there yeah if you
hit 10 then spawn the boss not sit there
for 30 seconds and wait for the timer
it's like you that's you telling me you
specifically don't want me to do this
any faster than this
so it's like there's those standout
moments from
the run
of like all the grind for the pages and
it is just that like there's some fun
lore that you might get out of it but
it's pretty hard grind and then like
some of these egregious things between
changing the drops the third the you
know the timer that you're gonna hit
where you can go fast or not
it's i don't know these and the live
events are you know hit or miss
sometimes man festival lost this or
can't win and once again today approved
it can't seem it was festival the cost
before and now you've just like nerfed
the drop rate festival for the cops yeah
i was never a festival guy al sandy says
don't forget 190 something pages yet you
can only hold 75 they're back yeah
you're capped at 75 yeah in caption
pages why can't you cap it at 200 so
then you'd grind all your pages no you
have to get some pages then go into the
haunted section get some pages get in
there you gotta gotta get some rotation
i love the caps the currency capture
it's a technical limitation
convincing me the good faith of the
vault at this point i have to say yeah
exactly right are we selling you well
oh does it always sound glorious
if you caught us on our lord lord
discussion like week when we were like
deep into what's going to happen with
savithoon and crow and witch queen and
all this stuff and you're catching us on
a low note
now i'm like oh man we are not selling
this thing it's so bad are we telling
this man right now
no no
travis said he hated the the haunted
forest i can certainly see that after a
number of years i can remember the first
year it was in and really liking it like
i thought it was yeah it was great the
first year yeah great the first year
yeah
yeah then they did it three more years
and i would say yeah and i don't think i
did but i remember that first year i was
playing with tom
and uh we're having a good time
yeah absolutely it was good that first
year uh i just i just i hate that they
retread it's like every year you know
exactly what's going to happen so at
least this year i didn't know it was
going to happen very cool they cooked up
something new that's awesome but
yeah it uh it's really not it's not good
and yeah the the caps the currency caps
they love their caps cog but again
no cap on the silver yep
never had a problem
you can have an infinite supply of
silver we have all the data fragments
for that one yeah no technical
limitation there quick question just to
start a small fight outstanding you want
to ask hogan uh what are your thoughts
on sunsetting exotics in this game
yeah
is this directed at me yes we've had
this discussion this one's for you
so i mean work me through the the
history here because i like i said i'm
not really trafficking in exotics too
often they were sun setting them and
then i thought they weren't so there was
going to be sun setting for legendaries
and basically everything from season 8
which was pretty much forsaken uh all of
that stuff got basically sunset so it
would not be able to be infused up to
the level where you're at
okay that was from season eight forward
that was in beyond light
during the season of beyond light those
first three months
they turned that off so anything else
that hadn't been sunset they basically
backtracked because it was going to be
like season eight and then season nine
was going to get sunset then season 10
was gonna get sunset rolling forward
okay when beyond light came out there
was so much blowback and they apparently
hadn't planned for this thing which was
kind of our speculation either way
they went back on that so anything that
was still active when beyond light
launched now is active forever and will
be going into the foreseeable future so
the question is
now legendary staring around or one
thing
but if the situation where sun setting
had stayed around they were never going
to do it to exotics
but
what are your thoughts would you what
would be your thoughts if they did it to
exotics
well to me it's it's a problem it's not
directly a problem with money right but
it's time like these things take your
time and the original pitch that i
understood for destiny was we wanted you
to have these cool stuff so you could
know the story of where you were and
remember what you were doing and who you
were with and how you felt and whatever
um so i do think if you start touching
that the core kind of defining principle
of how your
model is built for playing the game then
again it's kind of like vaulting
forsaken which is
how do i trust you the next time how do
i get involved in that situation the
next time
um so
i look at it as probably a good idea
that they didn't sun setting is already
kind of a problem just because i
actually i think this is what must have
happened i told you i was playing
forsaken two weeks ago and i'm not as
well versed in all of this stuff and i
really like that random bow they give
you right at the front end of forsaken
and they it was capped and i was like
why is this capped and i think that must
be a sunsetted bow um yeah so it's
i want to love it more than i do i mean
this is the problem i have with destiny
it keeps saying oh no we got dinosaur
armor rick come on
come on dinosaurs but also we're going
to cap everything
have you seen our transmog system it
seems like a parody of modern game
development
all these little things continue to
press down
and on the at the end of the day it's
like i have to decide what i'm going to
spend a relatively limited amount of
gaming time on
and
i'd rather not feel frustrated in most
capacities while i'm playing it even as
much as i like shooting falling in the
face
so just real quickly hulk um are you
implying that you know there's oh no he
flat said it
he flat said it you don't have to do
that
you're in cogs camp you're in good
company you're still allowed back on
last-man media you're good you're good
man i love that man
virtually subscribe put his channel in
the link right now come on
we're not doing the laundry it's always
funny when i stumble into somebody's
position this happens occasionally yes
no
i mean that that that's that's how i
feel that's what you sold i mean that's
the fundamentals of what you sold and i
do understand the flip which is like we
wanted to always be growing and evolving
and doing other things but yeah it's
tough to me when the winner when the
winners are decided it means that power
creep is inevitable they have to keep
making stronger and stronger weapons and
eventually the game just breaks on
itself so they have to
no i would say not necessarily
sunset weapons but they have to at least
nerf them they have to nerf weapons so
that new ones can shine and the game can
kind of change otherwise you know you
either don't have anything to hunt
because you already have the best
weapons you don't need anything in the
future and it kind of takes the looting
part out of the game or you're forced
into a power creep situation which
breaks it so live service games
live service games introduce new
problems
like that's the that's the reality of
the situation these are these are
unprecedented problems we're back to the
transparency concept right which is that
i think fundamentally bungie
wasn't positive what it was making or if
it was wasn't communicating with its pr
side of the company when it started
pitching this thing and so
i remember you're gonna tell stories
about that time you got the chest armor
with the fire in the belly and if that
goes away i mean something was lost for
what you told me you were selling me and
i agree with you travis i agree with
kind of the
it gets weird what are you doing in this
game what are you spending your time on
if you're maxed out on everything
but
i it's again it's it sounds like an
intractable problem i'm not getting paid
to develop video games so
if you can figure this out
you know i mean it's i want to love you
they they figured it out their their
solution was something
now their solution is not sensible you
know a lot of people have figured out
their problems by ditching rick it's
okay oh by the way rick um emma wanted
to let you know by the way when you
mention shooting fallen in the face by
the way we have allies that are falling
now we have a whole house that's hanging
out um
in the tower okay next to the tower
it's not cool
it's it's not it's not the bad fallen
it's the good fallen
no no i don't want to shoot the good
fall and i want to shoot the bad boy
they're still running around like the
cosmodrome right
oh yeah those are still there those are
of a different house but i was just
filling you in bits and pieces of the
story
there's also fallen houses involving
there's also a baby fallen they trying
to really humanize these guys you know
smalling yeah small ones well my
favorite race is the hive anyway are
they still good to shoot in the face yes
they're very good to shoot in the first
very very right now
we have a crystal
uh
yeah well she potentially will turn into
one yeah and i don't know if she's going
to be good better we don't know what's
up with her yet so speaking of narrative
if i could take one sojourn
does it
bother you or strike you as weird or or
flummox you in any way that
probably
the pitch for which queen comes out with
a sabbathune plot where as best i could
tell from the beginning that i watched
played when my brother did it is like oh
we hope sabathune doesn't go bad we've
got a plan and it's like i don't mean to
break this to you people in the plot but
i'm pretty sure it's not going to go
right right right yeah which is like
getting the end game trailer at the
front of infinity war isn't it which is
which is we we had yeah we had some some
trepidation here where people were like
oh we already know this is going to end
so this is going to be bad but i
actually think bungie is playing their
hand really well because they're using
the fact that you know how it ends to
just build up that tension you know it's
like you're it's like watching the movie
the titanic like you know how it ends
already before you've seen it but it's
all about kind of building so they're
doing a really good job but
yeah that's a good idea you can do that
with like historical events and that
kind of thing so it makes sense that's
what they pulled off that's good yeah
they have pulled it off we have to get
travis is right they they definitely
have a good job it's funny you mentioned
that because that was literally one of
that's one of ease like now you're like
getting at the e sensibilities of things
that kind of would bother you hates the
trailer spoilers he doesn't like that
like he wants to
be utterly you know surprised when he
goes in and i know that marketing
balance where it's like they want to
sell you the new thing and they got to
get you one thing on the solar system
right like i've been in there you can
only do so much
but yeah no i was curious i like what i
like what you said about yeah okay so
they're using it as tension because you
know how it ends because yeah yeah
savatune is coming and whatnot yeah it
just feels like the walls are closing in
on you whereas if we didn't know how it
ended we might just be like all right
we're helping savithoon because all the
other seasons have been about helping
our uh enemies as well and building
alliances with them and we know this
one's not going to work out and so every
week they're just sort of like you never
know this might be the week where things
don't go well for you it's been really
cool
all right no i like that i like that i
do
yeah they had a good day today this
bothers me it sounds like they are
getting good at storing it exactly right
it's just not it's just you have to
invest so much time to get it it's like
it's like you gotta you gotta pay like
50 bucks for like one bite of the
version at home what they're doing is
literally
the disney plus the netflix mod tune in
next week doing this little bit of
content and you can ask your question on
that i know it's live services and it's
and changes happening on a week-to-week
basis does that mean if you um if you
come in i know the six months screws
things up but let's just say you came in
seventy-five percent through
do you get to experience ketchup yeah
there you can catch up
you can do it all in one week right yep
so yeah if you jumped into seasonal or
whatever yeah if you jumped into
seasonal loss right now you could
literally play all nine episodes of the
tv show like that's basically the best
that's all right
that is good yeah yeah literally knows
that now he just waits because he he he
is he gets it patient with the story and
he like he comes in at the end of this
things and then finishes all that and he
gets all the narrative beats that he
wants and then he's out
literally it was just week one i think
and i was watching my brother and it was
uh mara and a crystal
and i was like i don't i don't have any
idea what's happening all we'll say is
just if you choose not to come back
because it seems like you may be out um
the way they handled
yeah i figured so so i'm just gonna take
one thing you know the way they handled
the osiris character and the deception
was really well played and they took a
character even though i like osiris not
really a beloved character that well and
and made it into this evil broading what
is he doing like what what is going on
why is he acting this way and then we
had the great reveal we've been fooled
yeah i saw the aftermath of that yeah
yeah that was like that was the big
reveal for him and i was like yeah okay
or as haters call him the curse of
osiris guy
oh
yeah
they want to reference his less loved uh
content
well for a couple other things that we
do have coming with regards to
i guess the rest of the game outside of
festival lost
uh this week we actually did get a
higher difficulty for shattered realm
which we've been talking about are
really fun kind of metroidvania zone
that we've all been loving and having
fun with
and then next week the six player
activity the astral alignment is gonna
get a higher difficulty it they don't
say it won't be match made but loadouts
will be locked and things of that nature
so i'll be kind of curious how that's
like
will be interesting with like loadouts
and champions and
as it will potentially be match made
still it's only 13 20 so you've been
playing enough you're probably there um
yeah but those two are going to be there
but i will say i did
you may not be and that's totally fine
too
but like i did shattered realm on legend
no i do like lost sector solo lost
sectors on legend
not that big of a deal like we kind of
got a pretty good sequence now
no shattered realm on legend will mess
you up
wow for you to say that that's that's
different like
yeah it's it's floating somewhere
between legend and by yourself though
right yeah you always are solo yeah i
mean but there's a triumph to do one of
them by yourself you can pick which one
i'll see which one's easiest but there's
a triumph to do one by yourself so i did
this one
there were plenty of deaths and i've
gone through i mean shattered homes not
like a difficult activity normally i
mean the mystery the investigation the
running around understanding all the
secrets is cool but the combat generally
isn't i would like that too because it
yeah it's very
metro vane travis you do a good job of
describing it yeah it's metroidvania
it's basically like they give you these
three little hub worlds and every week
one of them becomes traversable but the
first time you go through it certain
areas are closed off because you haven't
unlocked your powers yet and then as you
go through the episodes you you gain new
powers every week and then you revisit
the old areas except for they feel new
because you have access to new areas and
new puzzles that can trigger you can
trigger like rituals that are kind of
like these old side stories with their
own dialogue it's really cool what
they've been doing this week
only problem is you have to sift through
all the grindy normal destiny stuff that
you always have to do when you're
playing destiny to get to it and that's
like my biggest problem with destiny
right now it's like some of my favorite
stuff in the history and i'm going to
get this name wrong so i apologize was
um in destiny 1 when they introduced the
the ship in the asteroid belt
the leviathan what was it though
what are you talking about oh you mean
what the dragon the dreadnought i think
dreadnought sounds right yes
that's right where there were so many
like little um
like that is very much like that it's
very much that except for except for
these ones actually have dialogue behind
them and war and named characters it's
really cool what they're doing but
yeah
stores i don't know
there's a good there's a good game
hidden in here i focus what i'm trying
to tell you like they're like
the question is like one there's a
triumph through it solo there's a chance
to do it with groups even some people in
my comments of the video were like i did
this with like two people and we
struggled on beacon two which you'll
know when you get there it's all the art
guys
um
i even put a message out and i finally
got an answer here
and it says the chests are dropping high
stat gear so it's worth your while
and i'm going no it's not
yeah
like it's not that worth it when you say
hi stat gear i've bought enough tier
three umbral engram pieces of armor that
have dropped in the 50s that i'm all
really into oh so many
i've had such bad luck on those designs
yes me too yeah i've had like 57
is dropping a 50 yeah not five zero but
i've had like i've had 56 57 58
yeah sub 60 shouldn't be there
there's enough rng to the stats again i
still have a whole i can do a whole
podcast on armor but that's a problem i
just don't get i don't know why i get
why they're putting legendary content in
the game i think it's great we have more
options but they've really really
screwed up on the incentives like i have
no reason to do the legendary uh
shattered throne or shattered realm and
this this new thing with the uh astral
alignment they said that's gonna be live
next week they're adding a third chest i
don't even want the two chests you gave
me like don't add a third one like i i
shard that stuff immediately like you
know what i mean that's crazy it sounds
like a ketchup mechanic for the because
most people don't have do what is the
the scepter or the catalyst yeah the
catalyst will drop will drop uh higher i
i don't i don't have it i will yeah so
that it i think it's for those guys for
people who didn't do it initially now
they can it's if it feels catch-up
mechanically they don't even say it's
guaranteed if you do a random
matchmaking thing and if you all wipe
you'll actually go to orbit but you can
still get it on normal
think of it like what what's the what
they call it the protection rng what is
it when they're in the raid
protection
typical bungie trying to increase your
slot machine slightly with each failed
and the guy who wants radiographics to
still be random hey hey
just asking them if they can't just get
along with that matches up but
no the one thing i would say about the
exotics and raids
the problem with that is i don't crave
you are younger than us that's normal oh
i know i'm joking salad shop
yeah shh
go in timeout
turn your chair around
it's a destiny do you
oh yeah
[Laughter]
no i was gonna say like the randomness
on exotics and this happened to me on
gallahorn and it's the same reason it's
hard for me to like try to do the raid
so much
is i see some people go 50 times and not
get vex
how's that no how's that not anecdotal
like that's i see that multiple places
there are people who have like 10 20 30
40 50 and you could have anything in the
spectrum if i'm the unlucky one
like if it is anecdotal but it's also it
shouldn't happen yeah it shouldn't
happen so the fact that
the fact that there is no
limit to if i knew it was like hey if i
do raid once a week hey maybe i feel
like running two on characters i know
i'll eventually get there theoretically
if i'm doing like a raid once a week and
if i go 50 times that could be a whole
year
for nothing i'm gonna pull an ilp
where's the fraud alert on e right now
let me get the fraud
no i will no i will fully i don't rate
okay that often
no no no but that's why i don't that's
the key that's what i'm saying all right
let me let me still get you though
because this is where you still out you
still out of pocket here um
yeah i don't know let us have this one
um here's the thing
this is the same man that would do
legendary solar solo lost sectors which
we know because i don't have to depend
on anybody else's time or anything else
oh that's what it so it's the content
you like
solo and then it's okay no but okay so
the difference is if i go through that
activity there should be better
incentives at the end of say legend solo
shattered realm that's fine but if i go
through that activity if i'm like okay
let me find a group whether it's like
people that i know from chat whatever i
put them together do it and i don't get
it okay i don't get it that week and i
do it again and i do it again and i do
it again and i do it again and i'm gonna
start counting raids and i see people
have 50 tries i'm like
i know vex is nice but even if i start
trying now if i'm like okay i want to
start rating three times a week
everybody had 50 attempts on everybody
called not everybody some people got it
in two some people got it in 50. the
fact that that big of a range is there
is is my issue
we've been we've been praying to the
church of rn jesus from destiny's
inception yes but i'm not saying that's
how that should go
i should be protection percentage
is that is that not how it works do what
the
percentage apparently the percentage
apparently goes up but there's never a
yeah some people find a final one and
like last season i did the raid the
maximum amount of times for the whole
season and i never got it i got it in
the current season after it was and i
think i had done like 80 raids and it's
just like the the reward versus like
time investment is worth it should be
like uh you've done 10 raids and you
haven't gotten it yet you get 100
percent that's right what i've seen in
other contexts is you hit this number
it's yours that's right destiny does not
do that and i i i empathize with what
with what he's saying because i have
been on the uh receiving end of rng
being bad and and it's it's not it does
not feel fun it feels like it's
broken i was like there's enough other
stuff for me to do that's the other
thing is like where's my time best spent
i guess
and it's like is it going after one
weapon trying to put a raid together
potentially do it on multiple characters
three times a week to not get it for
you know if i'm gonna run raids some can
be fast for like two or three hours but
that's every single week or is it doing
other stuff and that's like
it's getting to a point where
at a
at if at an extreme level when i see
somebody hit 50 like that feels wrong
i'm not saying
me i don't rate that much i i'm fully
i'm full disclosure i'm saying that i
get that you can't throw me under the
bus to say that you can't agree like if
you say 50 is right then we will just
forever disagree that's all i'm going to
say is just you picking so what do you
think
you think there should be no protection
people should just forever be like up to
them
now okay
where's the where's the where's your
cutoff number yeah what's your max
i'm curious like 20 to 25 i guess i
don't know you don't say i don't i mean
i mean but if it's a start but
i think if i knew it was 20 to 25 at
least i know i could get there
like the re the way he's
blow the hitting with this is hilarious
but
to me when i i yeah fix your face so
here's the thing when i start the season
right and they say hey new exotics y'all
you know the season gotta get in those
lower sectors man and it'll it'll
usually be some really high-end warlock
exotic that cog wants with a passion he
doesn't see the blood sweat and tears i
i don't think that's right either no i
don't think that's right
i'm not a solo player right they want
you to have a specific loadout a
specific burn you can't do the law
sector with anybody else and then you
know what's the most disrespectful thing
hogue you go through this law sector
solo under-leveled everything is lashing
you everything hurts when you and then
you gotta fight that they got champions
and all this stuff in there right and
then you get to that chest you don't
didn't you get it
and you open it up and it's two blues
and an enhancement chord so i don't want
to hear no but i don't think that's
right either
i don't think that's right either great
you are guaranteed drops from the raid
each step of each encounter okay well
each steps change encounters about as
long as the last sector either way like
fair fair fair prayer
after this hug
but the only thing i'm saying is
i struggle the same way he doesn't like
playing in that six player raid zone i
struggle in his zone which is the solo i
just want to get in there and get down
it
you can only do this particular if you
want the arms you could only do it on
thursday after 5 p.m only on this day
and then you got to hope that the the
the weapon or the i mean the all the
armor comes up on of the day and it's
the light level that you could do so not
only do they randomize the light level
sometimes it's like oh thirteen fifty
you you have to do it it's like a random
it's a legend one day the next day it's
master yeah that you know how awful that
is when you're already under leveled
and you gotta go in there with the hope
it's at a low light level to even
attempt it or one day you only get one
day to do this then after that one you
can stay there all day wasting time and
you still don't get this thing that is
frustrating bro yeah
so
you know i like this conversation this
is interesting
um you know one of the things i advise
my clients on and is uh compensation
negotiations
uh and they're always asking you know
how do i set my number how do we have
this conversation
um you know how
is my employer mistreating me these
kinds of things
and i i generally have this counseling
and i talk to folks
and i tell them
you know for the most part it depends on
the employer obviously but a lot of the
job of the black box that is the
compensation committee is figuring out
what number is going to mildly annoy you
but not enough that you're going to
leave yes and
what i hear is
the
basis of this podcast the fact that
you're still talking about destiny and
dinosaur armor and everything else and
having fun with it to some extent and
are unhappy with the compensation you're
receiving
is suggestive to me that maybe that
doesn't work for rick
but it seems like if i were to analyze
this on a salary basis they seem to have
nailed you
right where you live which is
mild frustration
but still playing every day or to every
other day or whatever so we're all
frauds here we still you know it's just
it's it's pretty interesting to me
because i i totally hear you everything
that you've described is enough for me
to go do something else like i mean like
that's literally where i'm at and i
think that's the kind of personality
yeah i mean it's like
i could go play you know what final
fantasy 7 remake whatever i'm gonna go
play with the story and not worry about
these things
when does it stop being a salary
negotiation and start being stockholm
syndrome is my question
when does when is this a toxic
relationship that we're in with video
games
are we just gonna sunk is this a sunk
cost fallacy we're all just we have to
be here there is no question that
there's some cost at issue here but i
will say
i i like to frame that slightly
differently when i'm having this
conversation especially when i'm telling
somebody i think you should leave you
should do something else which is
sometimes the council there is human
nature there is inertia i know what i
know i know that maybe i'll get mildly
frustrated but i'll have some fun i'll
get compensated enough that i can
feed my video game family with whatever
utility i'm getting out of playing
destiny and
i i think that's kind of what happens
and then they do something bad to you
they take away your pages in your in
your uh lost sectors whatever else
they're doing and they say oh but come
on which queen is just a little while
away we're still good to you don't worry
about it we're gonna just take your
rates down just a little bit so we
didn't give you that weapon you wanted
you did the raid 50 times you still love
us come on
so what we're saying is that they're
gaslighting us is what we're doing
bungie is a pimp that's hitting us and
then uh and then uh giving us an ice
pack and being like see i take care of
you
i think some of these metaphors travis
get real dark we have questions we have
questions
can get exploited if you can get a
pieces i don't think that's i don't
think that's this level in particular i
think you see it a little bit more um
with like free-to-play mobile games
where you can really get into a space
which is uncomfortable
but
i i do see
that kind of conversation which i really
enjoyed by the way hearing you guys talk
about it um as
uh
yeah i hear that my personality type is
why am i doing this i think one of the
things that ivanta said which was right
is what happens to me in these grinder
games uh and destiny's not alone in this
i don't want to throw down
at some point i'm circling around doing
whatever going and getting leg armor or
whatever it is and like i'll i'll enjoy
it for i don't know five six seven days
and like seventh day i'll be like
what the hell am i doing
what am i really building towards what
is why am i why am i not playing
something that has a story to tell me or
that that is that is more for what i
want to do and like that's that's been
my cycle with destiny or even with like
i don't know fortnite which is just like
i get really into it for a while there's
some fun there there's some game
development there i'm enjoying it and
then i'm like well this just there's
just bars forever there's turtles all
the way down it's it's it's bars as far
as the eye can see
i'm gonna go do something else
that's my relationship with destiny i
pop in i play the campaign i try the
stuff i say cool i come in for the next
campaign generally speaking expansion
guy makes sense it makes sense a lot a
lot of people
have made that determination that you it
was it was a cathalian i think a couple
people yeah so they only come back for
the big expansions maybe maybe a tuesday
season like even goth i think is back
for some of the tuesday stuff but after
say like week seven he's not coming back
for seasonals he's not coming back for a
different difficulty he's not gonna
grind out the raid for
vex if he didn't get it he's not gonna
keep going at some point they just they
draw a line and move on until it's
something big enough
and that's why like when some people
talk about the whole sun setting or not
sun setting it's like a d3 is gonna wipe
stuff all over again i forget who i was
talking to or something like some of the
best times oh is rgh i was listening to
them i've been playing new world
it is not different than this by much
and if anything it's probably worse of a
grind but it's like new game level
numbers are going up and stuff like that
and it's just something fresh even if
it's another grind it's something new to
you and your brain
and it's the time when you're going
through it and it's like cool but
there's a point you know you'll hit and
i'm like okay it's like you know i'm
gonna take a break like i played death
loop
had a fantastic time finished it cool
and that's sometimes you gotta have some
experiences that haven't end because not
all experiences need to be indefinite or
you have to decide when that end is for
a healthy relationship because at some
point
it's unhealthy
i always have a forever game on the
shelf like i'm always filling in gaps
with that um now as i said i think it's
part of this video the the ubisofts are
so immensely large for the time that i
have to give to them those are usually
those count as my forever games i'll be
playing far cry 6 until my kids are in
college i mean like that map is
ridiculous so i mean like that's that's
how i work with those but yeah
absolutely i have a destiny or a
fortnight or a division or a far cry or
whatever that i'm playing next to
working through tales of a rise or
working through final fantasy remake or
whatever else i'm doing so i always have
a space for them um they're just never
like my top priority until like the
campaigns for destiny i'll go play
through them they're just not
even for your second you can hammer
through in like half half a day maybe
yeah it's a nice little enjoyable
evening i guess my my point with all
this is that as long as you're having
fun i'll never judge you if you play
destiny for 4 000 hours and you're
having fun every one of those hours i'll
never judge you my problem is with the
teddies of the world who tell me and i
quote my goal these days is to play
destiny as little as i can and he seeks
out the most efficient ways to get
through everything because he doesn't
seem to enjoy
any of it right and that's like why are
you playing them like you're just doing
it to fill up the bars you're not even
enjoying it and so i my goal every every
season of destiny is to play enough to
where i'm enjoying it and experiencing
everything without hating myself as soon
as i start hating myself that little the
little
self-hatred curve you know when you look
at yourself in the mirror and you can't
really make eye contact with yourself
because you're afraid of the man who
stares back at you when i reach that
point that's when i log off and i try to
do something else in my life that's
honestly been the healthiest thing has
been mixing in other games and the way
the seasons work like hey if it is a
tuesday game you experience the season
you got a little bit on tuesday or maybe
wednesday
you got to mix it up at some point
because if you find stuff that you said
if you find stuff that that's fun but if
you don't there's so much other amazing
stuff out there so
mix it up every so often you will thank
yourself
but i will say we have kept our guests
so much longer than i ever thought we
were going to sticking it out i
appreciate this man putting up with
another you know parental dispute we
made it through it
i liked it i really did i
one of the things i love about games in
general nobody can play everything and i
love finding spaces where people are
having interesting conversations about
stuff that i can i can understand like
the parameters even if i can't
understand the specifics yep um so i
actually i actually thoroughly enjoyed
that
appreciate you better again it's always
good to have you
one of the best legal minds and the fact
that you have passion for this franchise
at one point
and bunge is a hell of a developer no
question absolutely true
well
as we wrap things up uh this is the time
basically the floor is yours so sir rick
hogue of hoglaw
tell everybody where they can find you
anything you're covering anything you're
looking at your favorite supreme no we
covered that thanks travis i've got more
i mean it could be a top 10. um
together
is that like
yeah is that like one of the things for
law school top 10 supreme court cases
and i need you to argue why
yeah it kind of just happens yeah my
list is definitely everybody's you know
standard top when you're interviewing
with law firms oh yes marbury sure yeah
yeah i think two m's it's going to be
mccullough maryland so that's my i know
i know what i'm talking about what i do
my go-to is uh alien v predator i don't
think that one really gets talked about
enough you know it was really when the
justices said whoever loses whoever wins
we lose that it became a problem that's
right yeah that's true
no people can find me on uh twitter
certainly that's where i'm more kind of
like daily active
you know i try to not look at too much
stuff on there uh but at hoglaw
h-o-e-g-l-a-w
you can find me there chatting about
games or whatever my current video is or
the michigan wolverines that have all
been positive tweets so far mostly maybe
not all positive um but otherwise i
think most people find me and know about
me from virtual legality which is the
show i do on the business and law of
video games i think is probably 90 of it
um but just in general talking about
cool stuff like how wickard v filburn
works or supreme court contract
interpretation through the lens of a
destiny vaulting question
and hopefully talking to more people
about the stuff they're interested in
and how the law and business kind of
interacts with that because i think
people can have a better understanding
of the industry that they love and what
they're otherwise reading and then
hopefully it's a slow road but i'm
getting more and more uh influence and
work on uh you know bigger journalism
outlets and talking to them about when a
lawsuit happens and how that filing for
a debt offering isn't a merger and you
know slowly working up uh to hopefully
getting more and better information out
there but people can find me youtube.com
hoglaw same spelling or if you just look
up virtual legality i'm pretty sure i'm
topping google for virtual legality so
uh yeah and as for what we're working on
we just did that uh destiny vaulting
video of course uh tomorrow it looks
like if i'm reading my clock correctly
uh we'll be putting up a video on uh cw
cwa the communications workers labor
union uh is trying to intervene in the
activision blizzard eeoc settlement and
so
we did look over the 31 flavors of what
they're complaining about and if you
like an hour of me discussing union
complaints about an eeoc
consent decree i tell you i know the
channel you should check out uh so
that'll go up wait and sell it
yeah well look i got a very specific
community and my communities are adamant
oh yeah i was actually skipping this
document i said hey leave in the
comments if you want me to hit this um
the response was more vociferous than i
had anticipated so we'll be going over
that um and then you know chances are i
think next week i've got some some stuff
that i'm looking at i might do some
stuff on fifa license licensing which i
think is pretty interesting that's the
big one
and uh and some other
other things of that variety so if you
like games you like business you like
law
i think i make it less dull than it
would otherwise appear so come check me
out over there right true man salute to
hogue
always coming through just killing it
brother i'm just proud of you just to
see your progression and almost like to
see you be the de facto
voice in the community where it's like
oh wait hold on we got to get home
you'll see the tweets go out oh it's
like
he's like the community's personal
it isn't like that's this is a scoop um
i i can't give the specifics but i think
you'll be seeing me on some pretty big
panels pretty soon
i can't give the specifics
of all of all people who are going to
respect an nda a lawyer so don't ask
yeah no i i i think you're going to see
me popping up in a few places which are
pretty exciting so i'll give you guys
looking forward to it brother keep it up
keep it follow him on twitter and you
won't miss the hot takes
because that's the way i i talk and
sometimes i go out which is strong like
you and i interact travis and i always
feel like i have to be like okay just so
we're clear
i'm not bullying travis here we're just
fine
here we go
it's like context on the internet right
somewhere there's nothing that are a
thread calling me a bad name because i'm
sure travis i mean you know it is what
it is
classic it's the classic hoax dark
that's something we love as we love
that's right
good stuff brother love to see it
let's assume if it's on twitter it it
must be sarcastic that's the way i come
from it is that's the internet but
that's fine that's the internet
good-natured witticism's on there it
seems it's not entertaining to try to
come up with witty ways to say things so
that's what i use twitter for they're
hogismos there you go
yeah it's uh correct you're using it the
right way
travis what about you got any uh hot
takes yeah just be like stay tuned for
stay tuned for all of my hot takes yeah
um you can follow me on twitter at ty
guy travis uh i'm doing the review for
ign of the rift breaker which will be up
uh probably early next week we got uh
review codes late so i'm still working
my way through that
and i also do a
show on sunday mornings at 8 am called
bitcast where you can hear me talk to an
industry legend aims and uh also some
old guy that
wanders onto the set apparently
that is our panel
two
two uh well-informed people and a
geriatric
who somehow found his way into the show
that's the pitch
that's the wind up in the pitch how
about you e what are you up to
uh do i do cog first cog cog yeah what
do you got
right yeah we're out
oh yeah glory cognito on twitter you
know i do a couple of podcasts so
obviously shout out to the fatty duke we
had uh ryan mccaffrey on this week
check out the channel shout out yeah
really fun he had he had a rant of wall
rants and we got g checked by a legend
it was actually pretty fun so you kind
of uh put us in a place about why we
shouldn't even be called dukes uh
because we don't even have any type of
duke memorabilia any type of duke anyway
or afraid now you need to go on ebay and
change that yeah yeah we got we got xbox
og g check to the five legend but it was
amazing yeah yeah he he was a rare one
you should check that out um ultimate if
you're into more of a one or smaller
show we kind of did our like wishing
dreams for xbox back compat what we uh
what kind of like gaps what we're
missing and some old like uh cult
favorites catch that and um yeah uh
sunday iron lord pockets will be a
special one
[ __ ]
i can't reveal yet
all right all right
it should be it should be seth scheissel
formally of on protocol new york times
report right now believe count executive
for microsoft at xbox so
we're just trying to finalize it's
pretty much a goal we're just trying to
you know finalize one or two things
about things we can talk about so it
will be very interesting informative
great guy and just to see
look at the have a huge look at it give
him give him a run-through
he's like yeah my retainers more than
you want to pay so never mind
trust me i've dealt with huge prices you
can't negotiate against microsoft and
it'll be over exactly
check that out that should be sunday
will be fun and um yeah i think saturday
we're doing a live stream with uh the
lord's chivalry too so why listen to the
lord's yell across the battlefield say
wild chants to each other check that out
and of course
that last word podcast on thursdays
which i was the one we're in the middle
of right now
yes yes that go check that out man make
sure you're supporting it still one of
the best ones that most of you still
haven't supported yet but we're getting
there man i like i like seeing people in
the chat seeing people say kind words
that means a lot and it's always a
pleasure to do a podcast with these
amazing gentlemen even though we fight
like a family it's ridiculous
yeah you have to be like family to be
able to fight like this so it's a good
thing i'll take that true
absolutely what you gotta go to sir uh
let's see for me yeah um gotta jump back
into new world a little bit i had family
in town this past weekend so i feel like
i'm like way behind this season so kind
of keeping up with that stuff but
yeah apparently i've got to go see what
the grind is like in this event now to
see if there's a video coming and then
depending on what i got for this weekend
um yeah i'm mostly just kind of keeping
up on that type of stuff i watched squid
game which was just weird
yeah that was like that'll be something
to discuss later on um okay
but yeah and also saw james bond i
thoroughly enjoyed that one so
if you like him
give it a shot however you eventually
get to it um
what if you really hated spectre
you'll be okay
all right all right yeah yeah i was like
did you like sky fall did you like
like the scenery i will always be the
best
sky fall are great i found those ones
in the sun
yeah that's about right yeah so yeah so
i heard somebody say like the
alternation of good bad good bad
good
kind of [ __ ] kind of fits it's got mid
80s i think on rotten tomatoes and i
think that's fair
personal check it out
i will be curious yeah so
well thank you all all of you guys who
showed up who stayed to the end i think
some of you guys are in like the next
day depending on if you guys are across
the pond so thank you for staying up
very late shout out to emma and all of
you guys kevin new red coming in with
the hot information i wouldn't even
known about that tweet otherwise um
but yeah for this episode thank you for
the extended say sir hogue i don't think
we can afford you for this long but
thank you for the uh invoice party in
the mail don't worry about it oh cool
okay we appreciate it yeah
but for episode number one 69 oh is a
good number um
thank you all very much for coming we
are going to wrap this thing up thank
you so much and it has been
the last last word